Hey Craig, you know now that I have a child, a baby in the house, you know what I'm finding it hard to do?
嘿克雷格，你现在知道我有一个孩子了，家里有一个婴儿，你知道我觉得做什么很难吗？
What?
什么？
To remember to do?
要记得做什么？
What's that?
那是什么？
Eat food.
吃食物。
Eat food?
吃东西吗？
Yes, that's one of the basic needs that is no longer the priority.
是的，这是基本需求之一，但不再是优先事项。
I know, and I forget.
我知道，但我忘记了。
It's like, oh I forgot to feed Nelson, my dog, and myself.
就像，哦，我忘了喂尼尔森、我的狗和我自己。
So how are we going to solve that problem?
那么我们要如何解决这个问题呢？
Well, I just need something quick on the go that I won't, no must, no fuss.
好吧，我只是需要一些快速的东西，但我不会，没有必要，不用大惊小怪。
You know, I just need to feed myself and get some energy so I can get back to parenting.
你知道，我只需要养活自己并获得一些能量，这样我就可以回去养育孩子了。
Yes.
是的。
And so what would solve that problem?
那么什么可以解决这个问题呢？
I'm going to steer you towards an outcome and the outcome is this product you're about to mention.
我将引导您走向一个结果，而这个结果就是您将要提到的这款产品。
Oh, oh, wait, are you talking about Bavarian meat slow lamb, Yeager Snacksticks?
哦，哦，等等，你是在说巴伐利亚肉慢羊肉，Yeager Snacksticks 吗？
We agreed that's what, right before we started talking to Zoe, said that's what we're going to talk about.
我们同意，就在我们开始与佐伊交谈之前，我们就说这就是我们要谈论的内容。
Well, this is what I want to talk about.
嗯，这就是我想讲的。
The great tasting Bavarian meats, Lil' Lan Yeager Snacksticks, they sent us some of these and they are delicious and they solve the central problem of my life, which is I forget to eat.
美味的巴伐利亚肉类，Lil' Lan Yeager 零食，他们给我们送来了一些，它们很美味，解决了我生活中的核心问题，那就是我忘记吃饭。
They're naturally fermented, they're made with real ingredients, slow-smoked for bold flavor packed with 9 grams of protein per serving and have zero sugar and zero carbs.
它们是自然发酵的，采用真正的原料制成，缓慢熏制，味道浓郁，每份含有 9 克蛋白质，零糖和零碳水化合物。
Also I have a 19 year old boy, also a good moment to get a bunch of this product because he will eat us out of house and home and he loves this stuff.
我还有一个 19 岁的男孩，也是购买一堆这种产品的好时机，因为他会在家里和家里吃掉我们，而且他喜欢这些东西。
It's so great.
太棒了。
I'm very grateful we got, we got to sample this.
我非常感激我们得到了这个，我们必须对此进行采样。
My son is going to eat it all.
我儿子要把它全部吃掉。
I'm going to have like none of it.
我什么都不会。
But okay, it's a snack that keeps up with your day, whether you're racing between meetings or feeding babies or 19 year olds, doing school drop off, just trying to finish your to do list, take a moment to savor something delicious for you or your children.
但没关系，它是一种适合您一天的零食，无论您是在赶会议还是喂婴儿或 19 岁的孩子，放学时，只是想完成您的待办事项清单，花点时间为您或您的孩子品尝美味的东西。
And did we mention their portable toss a few in your glove box, your gym bag, the diaper bag, wherever.
我们是否提到过他们的便携式产品可以放在您的手套箱、健身包、尿布包等任何地方。
We have a diaper bag.
我们有一个尿布袋。
I bet you do.
我打赌你会的。
Better up to two or three of those bad boys.
最好是两个或三个坏男孩。
Pick up a pack today, your local grocer or stock up at bavarianmeats.com slash podcast.
立即从当地杂货店购买一包，或在 bavarianmeats.com 斜线播客上购买。
Use code mother 10 mother one zero at checkout for 10% off your first order.
结账时使用代码 mother 10 mother 1 0 即可享受第一笔订单 10% 的折扣。
The variant Meet snacks, sticks, great taste, zero sugar.
变体满足零食，棒，味道好，零糖。
Snapple would like you to take a break from the sheds.
斯内普尔希望你能离开棚屋休息一下。
Those things you should be doing, should be finishing, should be thinking about.
那些你应该做、应该完成、应该思考的事情。
Well, right now, just, oh, crack open a Snapple and just sit tight for a minute.
好吧，现在，只是，哦，打开一个 Snapple，静坐一分钟。
Well, Craig and I share some Snapple real facts with you, not unlike Mr. Mosby's fun facts.
好吧，克雷格和我与您分享一些 Snapple 的真实事实，就像莫斯比先生的有趣事实一样。
Mr. Ted Mosby would have a lot of his fun facts.
特德·莫斯比先生会有很多有趣的事实。
He would love these and some of these are even an architecture related.
他会喜欢这些，其中一些甚至与建筑相关。
So give us our first fact.
那么请告诉我们第一个事实。
What do you guys?
你们做什么？
These all feel like things Ted or at least like a future like dad Ted would say.
这些都感觉像是泰德的事情，或者至少像泰德爸爸所说的未来。
All right, here is a Snapple Real Facts 253.
好吧，这是 Snapple 真实事实 253。
The first TV remote control introduced in 1950 was called Lazy Bones.
1950 年推出的第一个电视遥控器被称为“Lazy Bones”。
I didn't know that.
我不知道。
Me neither.
我也不。
Real fact 1517 in New York.
1517 年纽约的真实事实。
It is illegal to sell a haunted house without telling the buyer.
在未告知买家的情况下出售鬼屋是违法的。
That's actually amazing.
这实际上是惊人的。
And that feels like a very, that feels like a very martial actually.
这感觉就像是一种非常非常武术的感觉。
These are weirdly resonant.
这些产生了奇怪的共鸣。
Okay, fact, that is amazing and I want to know more but we don't have time for it in the Snapple Chat.
好吧，事实上，这太棒了，我想了解更多，但我们在 Snapple Chat 中没有时间。
Real facts, 1978, 1,978 I'm gonna think has nothing to do with the year 1978.
真实的事实，1978 年，1,978 我认为与 1978 年无关。
More than 40 buildings in New York have their own zip codes.
纽约有 40 多座建筑物都有自己的邮政编码。
That is totally a Ted Mosby fund.
这完全是泰德·莫斯比基金。
That is.
那是。
He would actually know that.
他实际上会知道这一点。
He told every girlfriend that Snapple real fact, 1,667 lovebirds are actual birds.
他告诉每一位女友，Snapple 的事实是，1,667 只爱情鸟是真正的鸟。
Boom, and we bring you back to love.
繁荣，我们让你重拾爱情。
It's all full circle.
这都是完整的循环。
It's all very himmyamy.
这一切都非常他妈的。
All right, that's your break.
好吧，这是你的休息时间。
Quick fun and just a little unexpected.
快速有趣，只是有点出乎意料。
Next time you hit pause and make a count with Snapple on your next break.
下次您按下暂停键并在下一次休息时使用 Snapple 进行计数。
My name's Jan.
我叫简。
I'm from Spain.
我来自西班牙。
I'm 22 right now.
我现在22岁了。
Started high and met your mother more or less when I was like 14 or 15.
当我 14 或 15 岁的时候，我的起点很高，或多或少遇见了你的母亲。
You know, when you're 14 or 15 you don't really get taught things about your feelings, how to manage them, how to deal with them, how to love.
你知道，当你14或15岁的时候，你并没有真正被教导关于你的感受、如何管理它们、如何处理它们、如何去爱。
And these characters from Ham and your mother really taught me a lot about emotional intelligence, how to deal with my feelings, how to deal with people, how people feel about themselves as well.
哈姆和你母亲的这些角色确实教会了我很多关于情商的知识，如何处理自己的感受，如何与人打交道，以及人们如何看待自己。
I think it truly made me a better person.
我认为这确实让我成为了一个更好的人。
And it had a big impact in how I grew up, especially emotionally.
它对我的成长产生了很大的影响，尤其是在情感上。
And actually, I think when I was with my first girlfriend, the first time I told her I love you, I said falafel instead.
事实上，我想当我和我的第一个女朋友在一起时，我第一次告诉她我爱你，我说的是沙拉三明治。
And she watched the show also, so that was funny.
她也看了这个节目，所以这很有趣。
Yeah, thank you.
是的，谢谢。
I'm a loo, I'll be soon in New York City, when I see you.
我是个厕所，很快就会到纽约，见到你的时候。
Please permit me to tell you everything, book city.
请允许我告诉你一切，书城。
Hello, I'm Josh Radner.
你好，我是乔什·拉德纳。
Welcome to another episode of how we made your mother.
欢迎收看我们如何塑造你母亲的另一集。
I'm joined as always by my friend, Craig Thomas.
我的朋友克雷格·托马斯一如既往地加入了我的行列。
Hello, Josh.
你好，乔什。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
We also have our beloved producer and sometimes friend, Alec Lev here.
我们还有我们敬爱的制作人，有时也是朋友，亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev）也在这里。
some time.
某个时间。
Hello, Josh.
你好，乔什。
We're very excited.
我们非常兴奋。
We're talking about it.
我们正在谈论它。
He's always our friend.
他永远是我们的朋友。
What's your friend?
你的朋友是什么？
It's nice of you to say, we are talking with a sweet taste of liberty today, which first aired on television on October 3rd, 2005.
您说得真好，我们今天正在谈论自由的甜蜜滋味，该节目于 2005 年 10 月 3 日在电视上首次播出。
So on October 3rd, that'll be 20 years since this episode aired.
到 10 月 3 日，这一集播出已经过去 20 年了。
My God.
我的上帝。
We just don't understand this math.
我们只是不明白这个数学。
I don't think it's wrong.
我不认为这是错误的。
I think it's wrong.
我认为这是错误的。
We just agreed we would say the dates two seconds ago to contextualize it.
我们刚刚同意我们会说两秒前的日期以将其结合起来。
And as soon as you said it, that I felt sad and old.
你一这么说，我就感到悲伤和苍老。
I felt that she'll come through the room.
我感觉她会穿过房间。
Yeah, the grim reaper.
是的，死神。
So, okay.
那么，好吧。
So, sweetest of liberty.
所以，最甜蜜的自由。
This is episode three of 208, right?
这是208的第三集吧？
Episode three of 208.
208年第三集。
We're getting there.
我们快到了。
We're talking about all of you.
我们正在谈论你们所有人。
We've got a nice chill.
我们有一个很好的寒冷。
I mean, last week was two.
我的意思是，上周是两周。
This is, this is, we're really making progress.
这是，这是，我们真的在进步。
We really are.
我们确实是。
We're almost at the finish line.
我们快到终点线了。
Okay.
好的。
This is a fun one.
这是一件有趣的事。
I feel like parts one and two parts one and two episodes one and two felt like a two part it felt like an hour show rewatching it really felt that way and this feels like it's own show and away this is like also the show is this other thing that's a Barney cartoon that is exactly how the writers of this episode the wonderful Chris Miller and fill Lord Lord Miller you might know them from the leg homies you might know them from 21 Jump Street 22 Jump Street you might know them from winning Oscars for the spider verse mood reviews or at least an Oscar for the first one they got robbed on that second one.
我觉得第一部分和第二部分第一和第二集第一和第二感觉就像一个两部分，感觉就像一个小时的节目重看它真的有那种感觉，这感觉就像它自己的节目，而且这也像节目是另一件事，是一部巴尼卡通，这正是这一集的编剧精彩的克里斯·米勒和填充勋爵米勒勋爵你可能从腿部兄弟中认识他们你可能从21 Jump Street 22 Jump Street认识他们你可能通过赢得奥斯卡奖而认识他们蜘蛛侠的情绪评论，或者至少是第一部奥斯卡奖，他们在第二部被抢了。
And they're amazing.
他们太棒了。
And they were writers in season one of how I met your mother and they wrote this episode.
他们是《我如何遇见你母亲》第一季的编剧，他们写了这一集。
Remind me, did you guys work on Letterman Together?
提醒我，你们一起参与《莱特曼》吗？
How did you know them?
你是怎么认识他们的？
We had the same agent, our agent Matt Rice, who I'll give a nice compliment to here, he was very young.
我们有同一个经纪人，我们的经纪人马特·赖斯（Matt Rice），我要在这里对他表示赞扬，他非常年轻。
He was only a couple years older than all of us.
他只比我们所有人大几岁。
And he had his initial client roster when he was a junior agent was like me and Carter, Forte and Chris and Phil.
当他还是初级经纪人时，他就有了最初的客户名单，比如我、卡特、福特、克里斯和菲尔。
And a few other really, really cool people.
还有其他一些非常非常酷的人。
And it was just like, God the sky.
就像天空之神一样。
There is, there is something to a good agent.
一个好的经纪人是有一些东西的。
There are some who have some wrong states.
有些人有一些错误的状态。
I remember you telling me, or maybe Chris and Phil told me, that Chris was long time married and Phil was single mirroring you in Carter, right?
我记得你告诉我，或者克里斯和菲尔告诉我，克里斯已经结婚很久了，菲尔单身，这与卡特的情况如出一辙，对吧？
Insanely mirroring me in Carter.
疯狂地模仿我的卡特。
Yeah.
是的。
Chris and Robin went to Dartmouth and fell in love and were together the entire time in Dartmouth.
克里斯和罗宾去了达特茅斯并坠入爱河，并在达特茅斯一直在一起。
I'm Craig.
我是克雷格。
My wife is Rebecca C and R.
我的妻子是丽贝卡·C 和 R。
Kristen Robbins Kreg and Rebecca, Kreg and Rebecca.
克里斯汀·罗宾斯·克雷格和丽贝卡，克雷格和丽贝卡。
I'm just talking to myself and the third person for the rest of the episode.
在本集的其余部分中，我只是在与自己和第三人交谈。
It's not gonna get weird at all.
这根本不会变得奇怪。
What do you, what do you.
你做什么，你做什么。
Who did they create do next?
他们接下来创造了谁？
Craig and Rebecca, they met, those two met in college too and were together all the way through college.
克雷格和丽贝卡是他们认识的，这两个人也是在大学里认识的，并且在大学期间一直在一起。
So it was like this writing team of a guy, Chris, who had a, a C and R college relationship.
所以这就像一个由克里斯（Chris）组成的写作团队，他与 C 和 R 大学有关系。
And then his writing partner, Phil was like, a single guy, like Carter was a single guy and we were just like writing, we were doppelgangers.
然后他的写作伙伴菲尔就像一个单身汉，就像卡特是一个单身汉一样，我们就像写作一样，我们是分身。
I mean, to use him, you know, we were, did you, did you take Chris's wife's name for Robin Shurbatsky?
我的意思是，为了使用他，你知道，我们是，你，你把克里斯妻子的名字命名为罗宾·舒尔巴茨基吗？
So kind of because we moved out to LA and met this incredibly cool new person, Robin Murgeo, Chris Miller's then fiance or still girlfriend, they got married after we went to their wedding.
因为我们搬到了洛杉矶，遇到了一个非常酷的新朋友罗宾·穆尔吉奥（Robin Murgeo），克里斯·米勒当时的未婚夫或仍然是女朋友，他们在我们参加他们的婚礼后就结婚了。
And I remember it helped us want to name the cow.
我记得它帮助我们给牛命名。
I think we're talking about the name Robin and then we met like the coolest person in the world named Robin.
我想我们正在谈论罗宾这个名字，然后我们就遇到了世界上最酷的人罗宾。
We're like, yeah, this is a sign from the universe.
我们就像，是的，这是来自宇宙的标志。
So I would say, yeah, it influenced it.
所以我想说，是的，它影响了它。
Yeah, especially because you were you were Frankensteining her together.
是的，特别是因为你们在一起弗兰肯斯坦。
You that wasn't based on a real person, right?
你那不是根据真人改编的，对吧？
It was the one of the five that was not based on a real person.
这是五个非真人之一。
I want to say that I stole like traits from Robin Merge Yeah, but Robin Merge, he doesn't collect guns Most cigars No five dogs But there's there's something there and just the good energy.
我想说我从罗宾·合并那里偷来了类似的特质 是的，但是罗宾·合并，他不收集枪支 大多数雪茄 没有五只狗 但那里有一些东西，只有良好的能量。
She was like this amazing new person me Matt when we do LA and we're like there's some good karma here to put that name in there.
当我们去洛杉矶时，她就像是我马特这个了不起的新人，我们就像这里有一些良好的业力把这个名字放在那里。
By the way, I have nothing to contribute to this except if we're twisting this thing in on itself even more, how your kids, how you met your kids' mother if we're going back here, by the way that you met, you met Rebecca in college, is to tell them, tell them how that happened.
顺便说一句，我对此没有什么贡献，除非我们进一步扭曲这件事本身，如果我们回到这里，你的孩子，你如何遇见你孩子的母亲，顺便说一句，你在大学遇见丽贝卡，就是告诉他们，告诉他们这是如何发生的。
You've always got to get credit for shit, don't you?
你总是要因为狗屎而获得荣誉，不是吗？
I need to something.
我需要做点什么。
I need to wedge in your way in.
我需要挡住你的路。
Alan Clevve, producer extraordinaire, making this whole Godname podcast.
杰出的制作人艾伦·克莱夫 (Alan Clevve) 制作了整个《Godname》播客。
I guess we're calling this how we met everyone else.
我想我们是这样称呼我们认识其他人的。
So we're adding that's many seasons away.
所以我们要补充的是，这还需要很多赛季才能实现。
Alec was my college, dear friend in college, we lived in, I met him right away, freshman year, beginning there, and my wife had gone to high school with Alec and was a senior skill in high school and came to visit, thinking she might want to go to that school, too.
亚历克是我的大学，大学里亲爱的朋友，我们住在那里，我马上就认识了他，大一，从那里开始，我的妻子和亚历克一起上高中，是高中的高级技能，来拜访，认为她可能也想去那所学校。
And she had been friends with Alec.
她和亚历克是朋友。
She said, I'll come visit Alec and a couple other friends, Noah and Joel.
她说，我会去看望亚历克和其他几个朋友，诺亚和乔尔。
And she came and visited them and that is when I met Rebecca.
她来看望了他们，就在那时我遇到了丽贝卡。
So I guess you get some sort of credit.
所以我想你会得到某种荣誉。
It pains me to give you any credit for anything.
我很痛苦地把任何事情归功于你。
Some sort of.
某种。
But I guess, you know what you do.
但我想，你知道你在做什么。
I took credit at the wedding.
我在婚礼上获得了荣誉。
I'm taking it.
我接受了。
You definitely took credit.
你绝对是占了功劳。
You're meeting Rebecca when you were a college student and she was just visiting.
当你还是一名大学生时，你就认识了丽贝卡，而她刚刚来拜访。
Is your only whiff of scandal in your whole life?
你一生中唯一的丑闻吗？
Oh, it was scandalous because she is very smart.
哦，这是可耻的，因为她很聪明。
Aside, besides choosing me as a partner, she's usually very smart.
再说了，除了选择我作为伴侣之外，她平时也很聪明。
And she had skipped a grade in elementary school.
她在小学就跳级了。
So she was like 16 and a half.
所以她大约16岁半。
I was like 18.
我当时大概18岁。
Jesus.
耶稣。
So I did it may have there may be legal ramifications.
所以我这样做可能会产生法律后果。
I shouldn't be saying this on there.
我不应该在那里说这些。
She was, of course, wildly more mature than me at 18.
当然，她比 18 岁的我成熟得多。
And that is when we met.
那就是我们见面的时候。
When and how we met.
我们何时以及如何相遇。
And yes, I like you.
是的，我喜欢你。
Get some credit.
获得一些信用。
I'm going.
我要去。
I see you guys.
我看到你们了。
Well, let's let's move back to the episode.
好吧，让我们回到情节。
So Craig, you've talked about the pilot and purple giraffe as kind of being a two-part pilot.
克雷格，你谈到了飞行员和紫色长颈鹿作为一个由两部分组成的飞行员。
It establishes Ted's, you know, deep desire to get married, his kind of obsession and love of Robin, how Robin gets folded into the gang, we meet Lily and Marshall, they've gotten engaged.
它确立了泰德对结婚的强烈渴望，他对罗宾的痴迷和爱，罗宾如何融入帮派，我们遇到莉莉和马歇尔，他们订婚了。
Barney is this odd character in their lives who creates all this.
巴尼是他们生活中这个奇怪的人物，他创造了这一切。
I mean, he creates equal parts, great times and troubling times, but they keep them around.
我的意思是，他创造了平等的部分，美好的时光和麻烦的时光，但他们保留了它们。
And in this episode, Chris and Phil came to you and said, We want to do a Barney cartoon, like let's explore this character, yeah.
在这一集中，克里斯和菲尔来找你说，我们想做一部巴尼卡通片，比如让我们探索这个角色，是的。
Yeah, there are these animals.
是的，有这些动物。
They were very much animation guys and they've obviously done a lot more live action to you since then, but they were like, this needs to be the Barney cartoon.
他们都是动画制作人，从那时起他们显然为你做了更多的真人表演，但他们说，这需要是巴尼的卡通片。
This needs to be like Barney's bug's money and he's just taken us on an adventure.
这需要像巴尼的虫子的钱一样，他只是带我们去冒险。
He's just dragging us through insanity and they really, I'll give them a lot of credit, they really showed how far you could push Barney and make him just insane.
他只是让我们陷入疯狂，他们真的，我会给他们很大的信任，他们真的展示了你可以把巴尼推到多远，让他变得疯狂。
he does so many insane things.
他做了很多疯狂的事情。
This is this introduced legendary.
这就是传说中的这个介绍。
This introduced the incredibly tortured sort of like legion weight for it.
这给它带来了令人难以置信的折磨，就像军团的重量一样。
Baba, Derry.
爸爸，德里。
This, this did so many things.
这、这做了这么多事。
He's, he's literally at one point inside of suitcase and climbs out of a suitcase.
他确实在手提箱内的某一点，然后从手提箱里爬了出来。
It really is like a lunitian scarting.
这真的就像疯子的疤痕一样。
Yeah.
是的。
No, that's, I mean, I, I think I mentioned this, but like, that's the, that's the beginning of the master of disguise, right?
不，那是，我的意思是，我，我想我提到过这一点，但是就像，这就是，这就是伪装大师的开始，对吧？
Like the party as like we'll do anything and has done everything, um, the elaborate play.
就像聚会一样，我们会做任何事情并且已经做了所有事情，嗯，精心制作的戏剧。
Yeah.
是的。
And they really brought that.
他们确实带来了这一点。
I remember thinking, is it, is it too far?
我记得我当时想，是不是太远了？
Is this too insane?
这也太疯狂了吧？
Because Barney in the first two episodes, it's kind of like this needy guy who wants Ted's approval, right?
因为巴尼在前两集中，有点像这个需要泰德认可的有需要的人，对吧？
He just wants to be, and he still does in this one too.
他只是想成为这样的人，而且他现在仍然这样做。
He still constantly wants to.
他仍然不断地想要。
I love how insecure and fragile Barney is underneath the suit.
我喜欢巴尼在西装下的不安全感和脆弱。
But then you get that in this episode.
但你在这一集中就明白了。
You see Neil climb out of a suitcase and then string this tie and go on with his day.
你看到尼尔从手提箱里爬出来，然后系上领带，继续他的一天。
And you're like, yeah, I buy it.
你会说，是的，我买了。
I buy it.
我买它。
There's some of that Niel's commitment that you buy it.
尼尔有一些承诺让你购买它。
And then he says, um, believe it or not, that worked.
然后他说，嗯，不管你信不信，这确实有效。
And I wish I wish I could remember.
我希望我能记得。
I'm sure we had some backstory of like what he was saying to that woman to explain why he had been in the suitcase.
我确信我们有一些背景故事，比如他对那个女人说的话来解释他为什么在手提箱里。
But Niel also, like he is a magician.
但尼尔也一样，就像他是一个魔术师一样。
He, he, he's literally, like I think he was the head of the magic castle for years.
他，他，他真的，就像我认为他多年来一直是魔法城堡的负责人一样。
like he loves, he loves trickery and he loves an elaborate ploy and I think so much of the way he played Barney was this magic trick right like the whole character was a kind of um you thought you were watching one thing it was always something kind of something else it was a really kind of elaborately stacked deck the way he played it he was you always felt that there was something else underneath that suit there was something he was going to pull out and like Like, my favorite thing of what's underneath that suit is just how neat he is.
就像他喜欢的那样，他喜欢诡计，他喜欢精心设计的策略，我认为他扮演巴尼的方式很大程度上就是这个魔术，就像整个角色是一种嗯，你以为你在看一件事，但它总是在看别的东西，这真的是一种精心堆叠的甲板，他玩的方式他是你总是觉得那套衣服下面还有别的东西，他要拿出一些东西，就像，我最喜欢那套衣服下面的东西就是他是多么整洁。
Even in this episode, he's like Ted, he's trying to phone five Ted and he's like Ted, I know when you don't phone five.
即使在这一集里，他也像泰德一样，他试图给五个泰德打电话，而他就像泰德，我知道你什么时候不给五个电话。
And he's like, he's so attuned to wanting Ted's approval, even in this one where he's just dragged, he's just giving him this horrible night.
他就像是，他是如此渴望得到泰德的认可，即使在他刚刚被拖拽的情况下，他也只是给了他这个可怕的夜晚。
It's also funny that he's clearly coining things in like he's done him like twice, but he's declared it's a thing.
同样有趣的是，他显然是在创造一些东西，就像他已经做过两次一样，但他宣称这是一件事。
Like this is the thing we do.
就像这就是我们所做的事情。
But like, no one's ever participated before, Yeah, this is our thing, do it, you know?
但是就像，以前没有人参与过，是的，这是我们的事情，做吧，你知道吗？
Yeah, I feel like there's a chance that was the first phone five, and he's actually like, could do it all the time.
是的，我觉得有可能成为第一个电话五人，而且他实际上可以一直这样做。
Yeah.
是的。
And I wrote you this little ditty to send to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，寄给纽约的你。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hey, Alec.
嘿，亚历克。
Hey, Josh.
嘿，乔什。
I'm pretty excited for this autumn.
我对这个秋天感到非常兴奋。
Can I tell you why?
我可以告诉你为什么吗？
Absolutely, it's a lovely time in New York City.
毫无疑问，这是纽约市的美好时光。
Well, yeah, I've got a new album coming out and I have a single that's coming out and it's called October.
嗯，是的，我有一张新专辑即将发行，还有一首单曲即将发行，它的名字叫《十月》。
What?
什么？
We're hearing about it right here for the first time so I'm very excited about the fall about the autumn, especially the month of October.
我们是第一次在这里听到这个消息，所以我对秋天感到非常兴奋，尤其是十月。
And not only am I excited about the music, I'm excited to get comfortable and cozy because that's what fall on the East Coast or whatever place you are that has seasons is all about.
我不仅对音乐感到兴奋，而且也很高兴能够变得舒适和温馨，因为这就是东海岸或任何有季节的地方的秋天的意义所在。
And we don't need to argue about this.
我们不需要争论这个。
There are seasons in Los Angeles and every night it's fall.
洛杉矶有季节之分，每天晚上都是秋天。
That's true, that's true, you need a light jacket if you live in California.
是的，是的，如果您住在加利福尼亚州，您需要一件轻便的夹克。
Where can you get those light jackets and those sweaters and those perfect autumn, comfortable and cozy pieces?
哪里可以买到那些轻便的夹克、毛衣以及完美的秋季、舒适和温馨的单品？
Might I recommend Quince, which sent me an incredible sweater that is in heavy rotation?
我可以推荐 Quince，它给我寄来了一件令人难以置信的毛衣，而且经常轮换吗？
Also, I picked out one, or actually, Jordana picked it out, a sweater from Quince, that is also in heavy rotation.
另外，我挑选了一件，或者实际上，乔丹娜挑选了一件，来自 Quince 的一件毛衣，这件毛衣也在大量轮换中。
So we are set for the fall.
所以我们已经准备好迎接秋天了。
We keep going back to these sweaters.
我们不断回到这些毛衣。
They work with almost our entire closet is just earth tones because that's kind of what we work with.
它们与我们的整个衣柜几乎都是大地色，因为这就是我们的工作方式。
But it matches with everything.
但它与一切都很相配。
So we're delighted with our pieces from Quince and I think you would be too.
因此，我们对 Quince 的作品感到非常满意，我想您也会如此。
So upgrade your everyday.
所以升级你的日常生活。
Download the Quince app for app exclusive offers or go to quince.com slash your mother pod.
下载 Quince 应用程序以获得应用程序独家优惠，或访问 quince.com 削减你的母豆荚。
Get free shipping on your order and 365-day returns now available in Canada and the UK too.
加拿大和英国现在也提供订单免费送货和 365 天退货服务。
That's q-u-i-n-c-e.com slash your mother pod.
那是 q-u-i-n-c-e.com 削减你的母亲 pod。
I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed podcast.
我是 Alex Goldman，HyperFixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
诸如此类的问题：我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车，或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radio Topia.
这是来自 Radio Topia 的 HyperFixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts, or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客，或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
Hey, Alex.
嘿，亚历克斯。
Josh, remember those legendary freezer pops from childhood summers?
乔什，还记得童年夏天那些传奇的冰柜汽水吗？
You know the one I'm talking about.
你知道我正在谈论的那个人。
The red, white, and blue ones.
有红的、白的、蓝的。
It is the only thing I remember from childhood.
这是我从小到大唯一记得的事情。
That's right.
这是正确的。
They pretty much ruled the neighborhood pools and playgrounds, your face should be covered with your finger.
他们几乎统治了附近的游泳池和游乐场，你应该用手指遮住脸。
It was just a delightful summer memory.
这只是一个愉快的夏日记忆。
Well, five hour energy has taken that iconic nostalgia and reimagined it as a bold, refreshing, fireworks freeze energy shot.
嗯，《五小时能量》消除了这种标志性的怀旧情绪，并将其重新想象为大胆、清爽、烟花冻结的能量镜头。
Every single sip delivers a massive flavor explosion like the original pops of which you speak.
每一口都会带来巨大的味道爆炸，就像你所说的原始流行音乐一样。
Expertly blending, juicy cherry, citrusy lime, and sweet blue raspberry to completely ignite your taste buds.
熟练地混合多汁的樱桃、柑橘酸橙和甜美的蓝覆盆子，彻底点燃您的味蕾。
It's that fruity taste that you crave created with zero sugar, so you can enjoy the full experience, guilt-free.
这是您渴望的零糖果味，因此您可以毫无负罪感地享受完整的体验。
Whether you're conquering a packed schedule, tackling a mid-afternoon slump at your desk, headed out on a weekend road trip or just looking to spark a vibrant new flavor sensation, this portable shot is the perfect daily companion.
无论您是要克服繁忙的日程、解决午后在办公桌前的困倦、周末公路旅行还是只是想激发一种充满活力的新风味，这款便携式镜头都是完美的日常伴侣。
Give your routine an exciting upgrade with a mouth-watering twist on a timeless favorite.
为您的日常生活带来令人兴奋的升级，为永恒的最爱带来令人垂涎的变化。
Ignite your taste buds with a firework-free, flavored five-hour energy shot now available online at 5ourenergy.com or Amazon.
现在，您可以在 5ourenergy.com 或 Amazon 上购买五小时的无烟火风味风味能量饮料，点燃您的味蕾。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
He just wants to belong.
他只是想要归属感。
He's so badly wants to belong.
他非常想要归属。
Yeah.
是的。
That's what I got from these early Barney episodes.
这就是我从巴尼早期剧集中得到的信息。
And maybe we lost our way at certain points later where you made him too literally the thing.
也许后来我们在某些时候迷失了方向，你把他塑造得太过分了。
But what I really love about these early ones is he's just so fragile and needy.
但我真正喜欢这些早期的人的是他是如此脆弱和需要帮助。
It's and I think it like gives Ted such power.
我认为它赋予了特德如此的力量。
But it's also it's also power Ted never asked for.
但这也是特德从未要求过的权力。
Now like it's like it's like power that was thrust in Ted's lap and he's like man, I don't I don't want to be the guardian of your self esteem.
现在就像权力被推到了特德的腿上，他就像一个人，我不，我不想成为你自尊的守护者。
Like I can't be like always telling you you know affirming you and going on these adventures.
就像我不能总是告诉你你知道肯定你并继续这些冒险一样。
But okay so talk us through the plot like like how what was your kind of initial inspiration for this beyond a cartoon the the episode the two questions of this episode I remember talking about in the redder's room were why are they friends with this insane guy who wear suits and just like says insane things and doesn't seem to how do we make the sale of why Barney's their friend and then the other thing we're trying to make the sale on was showing Robin and Lily becoming friends like we really they really just met Robin they don't have a dynamic you know like Barney Barney has been with them for years like I think he does invent things and pretend that that they always do it.
但是好吧，请告诉我们这个情节，比如除了卡通片之外，你对这一集的最初灵感是什么，这一集的两个问题我记得在红人的房间里谈论过，为什么他们是这个疯狂的家伙的朋友，他穿着西装，就像说着疯狂的事情，似乎我们如何推销为什么巴尼是他们的朋友，然后我们试图推销的另一件事是展示罗宾和莉莉成为朋友，就像我们真的一样，他们真的刚刚认识了罗宾他们没有像巴尼那样的活力，巴尼已经和他们在一起很多年了，我认为他确实发明了东西，并假装他们总是这样做。
I love that observation, Josh.
我喜欢这个观察，乔什。
But I think like they have history.
但我认为他们有历史。
Robin and Lily, we just were like, we just got to get them together and show them having a cute fun night at the bar.
罗宾和莉莉，我们只是想，我们只需要把他们聚在一起，让他们在酒吧度过一个可爱有趣的夜晚。
Those were the two missions.
这是两个任务。
And we wanted to end an episode that says why is why does Barney add value to this group and making the sale to the audience of like, okay, the first two episodes were really heartfelt.
我们想要结束一集，说明为什么巴尼为这个群体增加了价值，并向观众推销，好吧，前两集真的很真诚。
It was really Ted Hart forward those first two episodes.
前两集确实是泰德·哈特（Ted Hart）转发的。
I loved how they felt like an hour.
我喜欢他们一个小时的感觉。
I feel like you could just watch that as an hour of those first two months.
我觉得你可以只看前两个月的一个小时。
And it felt that way much more than I remember showing that way at the time.
这种感觉比我记忆中当时表现的要强烈得多。
The third one, this one is just like we're just going to try something different.
第三个，这个就像我们要尝试一些不同的东西。
This is just going to be a different kind of song.
这将是一首不同类型的歌曲。
And it had to make the sale of like Barney, you're going to want to watch Barney.
它必须像巴尼一样出售，你会想看巴尼。
He's going to bring you crazy places.
他会给你带来疯狂的地方。
You never would have gone.
你永远不会走。
Yeah.
是的。
And I like the generosity at the end of Sagitt, Sagitt's voiceover is really nice at the end of that's why we hung out with Barney.
我喜欢萨吉特最后的慷慨，萨吉特最后的画外音非常好，这就是我们和巴尼一起出去玩的原因。
Right.
正确的。
You wound up somewhere.
你最终在某个地方。
You never would have been.
你永远不会。
You wound up with the story.
你结束了这个故事。
And the proof is that he's telling the kids that story.
证据就是他正在给孩子们讲这个故事。
It's the night they went to lick the Liberty Bell, it's the night they did that, and Barney's always looking for these superlatives in this kind of damaged, searching, needy, strange way, needing to feel superlative and special.
那是他们去舔自由钟的那一晚，那是他们这么做的那晚，巴尼总是以这种被破坏的、探索的、匮乏的、奇怪的方式寻找这些最高级的东西，需要感觉最高级的和特别的。
It's also a real, he's addicted to novelty.
这也是真的，他对新奇事物上瘾了。
He wants to be the first one to do something.
他想成为第一个做某事的人。
He wants to create these stories.
他想创作这些故事。
No one's ever done this before.
以前没有人这样做过。
And also his inability to commit and always having to be with a new woman is like this kind of rotating.
而他无法做出承诺，总是不得不和一个新女人在一起，就像这种轮换。
It's this is not he's a dopamine search.
这不是他在寻找多巴胺。
You know, he's a different like the dopamine hit of the new but and yet Minnaga mislead committed to Ted Absolutely, it's his greatest relationship.
你知道，他是一个不同的人，就像新的多巴胺冲击一样，但明纳加误导了泰德，这绝对是他最好的关系。
It's his greatest longest relationship.
这是他最伟大、最长的关系。
It's his greatest and longest relationship And it's like genuinely sweet.
这是他最伟大、最长的关系，而且真的很甜蜜。
He's a needy Ted has the upper hand in that relationship in a lot of ways Yeah, Ted is dragged through this insanity.
他是一个需要帮助的人，泰德在这段关系中在很多方面都占据了上风，是的，泰德被这种疯狂所拖累。
He winds up, you know detained by like TSA.
他最终被 TSA 之类的人拘留了。
I mean Ted has a bad night of it but in the end, he looks back fondly.
我的意思是特德度过了一个糟糕的夜晚，但最终，他满怀深情地回顾过去。
But Josh, remember you were saying watching it, you were like, I wish there were a couple more moments where we had Ted, either in the writing or the playing of it, or both, where we had Ted enjoying it more, being like a few more little moments where Ted's like, all right, yeah, this is kind of fun.
但是乔什，记住你说看它，你就像，我希望有更多的时刻，我们有泰德，无论是在写作还是演奏中，或者两者兼而有之，我们让泰德更享受它，就像泰德更多的一些小时刻，好吧，是的，这很有趣。
Which I guess fights against the ending of the ending is when he realizes that.
我想当他意识到这一点时，就会与结局的结局相抗衡。
But yeah, I know what you mean.
但是，是的，我知道你的意思。
That was, you made that observation when we were talking about it before.
就是说，您在我们之前讨论的时候也说过这样的话。
That's the same way about that.
这也是同样的道理。
Like, do you feel like?
比如说，你有这样的感觉吗？
Yeah, I mean, when I was watching it, So, so the first two episodes, Ted is not only heart-forward, but he's like, plot-forward.
是的，我的意思是，当我看的时候，所以，前两集，泰德不仅是内心的前向，而且他的情节也很前向。
He's the engine of the plot.
他是剧情的引擎。
The motor.
电机。
Everyone is kind of reacting around his mania and his drive and his passion.
每个人都会围绕他的狂热、他的动力和他的激情做出反应。
And I found that was very easy to play.
我发现这很容易玩。
I understood how to play that.
我明白怎么玩了。
In this episode, I think I misjudged it like if I could go back and adjust the dial.
在这一集中，我想我误判了它，就像我是否可以回去调整表盘一样。
I would have, I found it that Barney's the driver of this episode.
我会的，我发现巴尼是这一集的司机。
I will say this, I have such a strong memory and these little things stick out at you.
我要说的是，我的记忆力很强，这些小事让你印象深刻。
When we were on the New York street, I'm walking Ted's walking with Marshall and Lily and Bernie pulls up in the cab, right?
当我们在纽约街上时，我正在散步，特德和马歇尔、莉莉一起散步，伯尼在出租车里停下来，对吗？
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And he's like, get in, right?
他说，进来吧？
Yeah.
是的。
I remember there was a look in Neil's eyes.
我记得尼尔的眼睛里有一种神色。
That I will never forget.
我永远不会忘记。
And it was like, he had dropped into a new level of barniness.
就好像，他已经陷入了一个新的疯狂状态。
Yeah, yes, there's 100% to talk about.
是的，是的，有100%可以谈论。
The energy, yeah, I get it.
能量，是的，我明白了。
That's Christian.
那是基督教。
And it also looked like I'm taking this episode, like I'm taking it, I'm taking this.
看起来我正在接受这一集，就像我正在接受它，我正在接受这个。
And I felt a little bit like I was just along for the ride.
我感觉有点像我只是随波逐流。
Now the fun parts of it for me and it's literally a hostage situation.
现在对我来说最有趣的部分是，这实际上是一场人质事件。
That's right.
这是正确的。
How does he have a cab driver lock that locked Ted in?
他是怎么用出租车司机锁锁住特德的？
That's the bond doors like he has such a deep relationship already with the cab driver.
那是债券门，就像他已经和出租车司机有着深厚的关系一样。
With the cab driver.
和出租车司机一起。
Yeah.
是的。
That is based on we always had a friend who always like very much got the cab driver's name and would always have like that's a ranger like it was it was a friend of ours.
这是基于我们一直有一个朋友，他总是非常喜欢知道出租车司机的名字，并且总是喜欢那是一个护林员，就像它是我们的朋友一样。
And a lot of them write it would always do that and sort of take over the cabin away like best of brightest.
他们中的很多人写道，它总是会这样做，并像最聪明的人一样接管小屋。
I don't know how Esteban can lie.
我不知道埃斯特班怎么能撒谎。
It's a little creepy to contemplate.
想想都有点毛骨悚然。
How can Esteban lock Ted in?
埃斯特班怎样才能把泰德锁起来？
I don't want to think about that.
我不想考虑这个。
But what I what I liked about it especially in the interrogation scene which is kind of a classic himium.
但我最喜欢的是它，尤其是在审讯场景中，这是一种经典的“hiium”。
That is a great scene.
那是一个伟大的场景。
It's so funny.
太搞笑了。
The security guard is so funny.
保安太搞笑了
The main guy is so funny.
男主角太搞笑了
But what I felt was at At its best, it establishes Ted and Barney as a kind of Abbott and Costello Laurel and Hardy, like a classic Vodville team, where you have the crazy one, and then you have the eye roller, right?
但我的感觉是，在最好的情况下，它把泰德和巴尼塑造成一种雅培和科斯特洛劳雷尔和哈代，就像一个经典的沃德维尔团队，在那里你有疯狂的，然后你有眼球滚动的，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
And that was your job in this one.
这就是你的工作。
You have to be the straight man, which is arguably the most important part of the equation.
你必须是一个正直的人，这可以说是这个等式中最重要的部分。
It's called in the heart.
是在心里呼唤着。
This is why I'll always love Mike Sure, who created many classic television shows, Parks and Rec, and Brooklyn 99, and they're all brilliant shows.
这就是为什么我永远喜欢迈克·苏尔（Mike Sure），他创作了许多经典电视节目，《公园与休闲》（Parks and Rec）和《布鲁克林99》（Brooklyn 99），它们都是精彩的节目。
but he wrote a piece after Harold Raimus died.
但他在哈罗德·雷姆斯去世后写了一篇文章。
I think Esquire about how there's no Bill Murray without a Harold Raimus.
我认为 Esquire 认为没有哈罗德·雷姆斯就没有比尔·默里。
A hundred percent.
百分之一百。
Like you can.
就像你可以的那样。
I mean, Egon in Ghostbusters, Egon is like that movie in so many ways.
我的意思是，《捉鬼敢死队》中的埃贡在很多方面都像那部电影。
Like, and how brilliant he was at like holding down the center so the crazy person can be crazy.
就像，他多么聪明，就像按住中心一样，这样疯狂的人就可以疯狂。
Yes.
是的。
And that's hard.
这很难。
That was your job, but that's actually hard.
那是你的工作，但这实际上很难。
And I feel like the, the, like I ran into a metaparty and I told him I was like, I just felt so seen by that article because that's what I had to do on how I made my mother.
我觉得，就像我遇到了一个元派对，我告诉他我觉得，我只是觉得那篇文章让我很受关注，因为这就是我必须做的关于我如何成为我母亲的事情。
And he said to me, he goes, well, he goes, you and John Krasinski and Adam Scott will never win Emmys for these shows, but these shows cannot work without you.
他对我说，他走了，好吧，他走了，你和约翰·卡拉辛斯基和亚当·斯科特永远不会因为这些节目赢得艾美奖，但这些节目没有你就无法运作。
But there's no show without that role.
但没有这个角色就没有演出。
There's no show.
没戏了
But in some ways, I just wish, because I was, I was placed, I, I, the first two episodes I was so active.
但从某些方面来说，我只是希望，因为我，我被安置，我，我，前两集我这么活跃。
And in this one, I was basically reactive.
在这一次，我基本上是被动的。
Yeah.
是的。
And I wish that there had been some softening of my response to it.
我希望我对此的反应能有所软化。
That said, he does have to blow up at him.
话虽这么说，他确实得对他发脾气。
He does get annoyed, you know.
他确实会生气，你知道的。
But I know what you mean.
但我知道你的意思。
I know what you mean.
我知道你的意思。
I think it's the right of hitting something a little hard.
我认为用力击打某物是正确的。
But I think it's brilliantly constructed the episode, you know, it's really constructed to do what you wanted to do.
但我认为这一集的构建非常出色，你知道，它确实是为了做你想做的事情而构建的。
And I also think one more thing.
我还想到一件事。
I realize I'm on our tear here.
我意识到我在这里泪流满面。
You're still teaching the audience how to watch how I met your mother.
你还在教观众如何观看我是如何遇见你母亲的。
You're also teaching yourself what the show is and what it's capable of.
你也在教自己这个节目是什么以及它的能力。
Yes, it's episode three.
是的，这是第三集。
So you have this pattern established.
所以你已经建立了这个模式。
This, you know, what do they say?
你知道，他们怎么说？
There's like 17 plots or something.
大概有17个地块之类的。
Like like the first one is one plot essentially.
就像第一个本质上是一个情节。
That seems high.
看来这个很高啊
I mean, there's like five.
我的意思是，大约有五个。
Maybe there's five plots.
也许有五个情节。
The second one is no, no, no, we can also do this.
第二个不不不，我们也可以这样做。
It's like a superhero discovering another power.
这就像超级英雄发现了另一种力量。
Like we can also let Barney be an insane engine of, of, of mania and wild ideas.
就像我们也可以让巴尼成为狂热和疯狂想法的疯狂引擎。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
So yeah.
所以是的。
The show is auditioning to the audience still in this episode.
该节目仍在本集中向观众试镜。
All of season one is auditioning.
第一季全部都是试镜。
What, what other moves do we have?
什么，我们还有什么动作？
We showed you the TED, essentially an hour long like TED heartfelt story.
我们向您展示了 TED，基本上是一个小时长的类似 TED 的感人故事。
And now this next one, which almost feels like episode two the more I talk about it, because I keep on thinking of the first one as an hour.
现在是下一个，我谈论得越多，感觉就像第二集，因为我一直认为第一集是一个小时。
This had to show a new move.
这不得不表现出新的举动。
This had to show a new move and how do you show the two ladies together?
这必须展示一个新的举动，你如何展示这两位女士在一起的情况？
We needed that.
我们需要那个。
them to become friends.
他们成为朋友。
And I like them together.
而且我喜欢他们在一起。
I will say while we're expressing mild regrets, I like that story.
我想说，虽然我们表达了轻微的遗憾，但我喜欢这个故事。
I think they were cute together.
我觉得他们在一起很可爱。
I think I'd actually set up some good things of Lily like wrestling with like, oh, I'm an engaged lady now.
我想我实际上会为莉莉设置一些好的东西，比如摔跤，哦，我现在是一位订婚的女士了。
And that sort of plants a little bit of a seed for later in the season spoilers, things that might happen about her attitude towards am I getting married to young.
这种行为为本季后期的剧透埋下了种子，她对我是否要嫁给年轻人的态度可能会发生一些事情。
It's like there's a little seed planted there.
就好像那里埋下了一颗小种子。
But I will say when I watch this one, it's a very sort of linear that story between her and Robin.
但我会说，当我观看这个时，她和罗宾之间的故事非常线性。
It's very much like it could be another sitcom.
这很像是另一部情景喜剧。
Do you know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
It's like they're in the bar.
就好像他们在酒吧里一样。
There's sort of a series of beats.
有一系列的节拍。
We don't play with time that much.
我们不太玩弄时间。
It's fun at the end how the two stories kind of dovetail Marshall comes in.
有趣的是，最后这两个故事是如何吻合的，马歇尔的出现。
Thanks, the guys hitting on her.
谢谢，那些攻击她的人。
There's things I like about it and I just like them.
有些事情我很喜欢，而且我就是喜欢它们。
It was the right move to put those two ladies together.
将这两位女士放在一起是正确的举动。
But from a writing perspective, I watched it and I thought, boy, the Barney story is this very fun cartoon.
但从写作的角度来看，我看了它，我想，男孩，巴尼的故事是一部非常有趣的动画片。
There's three-way split screens.
有三向分屏。
There's intercuts, Marshall's driving, Marshall's singing crazy songs.
有插播，马歇尔开车，马歇尔唱着疯狂的歌曲。
Barney's climbing at a suitcase.
巴尼正在爬手提箱。
There's There's high, high angle security camera, black and white footage, and there's like, you're just in this world, and then you go to the bar, and it's all kind of linear.
有高、高角度的安全摄像头，黑白镜头，就像，你就在这个世界上，然后你去了酒吧，一切都是线性的。
And maybe that's okay, and they offset each other.
也许这没关系，而且它们相互抵消。
But I remember feeling like, this isn't as him, you me, this B story, this Lily, Robin B story.
但我记得当时的感觉是，这不是他、你、我，这个 B 故事，这个莉莉、罗宾 B 的故事。
I remember feeling like, maybe that's the sign of early times where we didn't quite figure out a way within that linear story to kind of make it work.
我记得当时的感觉是，也许这就是早期的迹象，我们在线性故事中还没有找到一种让它发挥作用的方法。
I will say, it felt psychologically honest to me in that Lily is reckoning with this feeling that a phase of her life is done, like going to a bar and spotting a guy across the room and him coming over and talking, like, she's not going to have that anymore.
我会说，对我来说，心理上感觉很诚实，因为莉莉正在考虑她生命中的一个阶段已经结束的这种感觉，就像去一家酒吧，发现房间对面有一个男人，他走过来说话，就像，她不会再有这样的感觉了。
And Robin seems to have that just endless in the episode.
罗宾在这一集中似乎有无穷无尽的东西。
But I really like what Robin says, you know, you have what we're all here looking around for.
但我真的很喜欢罗宾所说的，你知道，你拥有我们都在寻找的东西。
made it land.
成功着陆了。
That's what made it land.
这就是它落地的原因。
And that's what made me feel like they were friends.
这就是让我觉得他们是朋友的原因。
I feel like we made the sale.
我觉得我们成功了。
That was, I love that moment.
那就是，我喜欢那一刻。
I love how she says that, Joe.
我喜欢她这么说，乔。
Everybody here is looking for what you already got.
这里的每个人都在寻找你已经拥有的东西。
Yeah.
是的。
And that's, that's tonight.
就是这样，就是今晚。
That's, Joe.
那是，乔。
And also the, the, our favorite girl in the pilot who says, what's taken so long?
还有飞行员中我们最喜欢的女孩，她说，怎么花了这么长时间？
Like, you get the feeling like Robin just hadn't found her tribe in New York.
就像，你会感觉罗宾只是没有在纽约找到她的部落。
And suddenly, it's not just Ted.
突然之间，这不仅仅是特德。
It's like, oh, this is a girlfriend.
就像，哦，这是一个女朋友。
There's Because this is a new, good, deep girlfriend who I can talk with, I can be honest with.
因为这是一个新的、好的、深沉的女朋友，我可以和她交谈，我可以诚实地对待她。
You really do need to establish that, and I think it was well done.
你确实需要确定这一点，而且我认为做得很好。
What I loved about the end of Purple Giraffe episode two is Ted invites, Ted knows he's got this treasure chest full of wonderful humans that he can offer to Robin if he can only get over his own feeling that he's been rejected by her.
我喜欢《紫色长颈鹿》第二集结尾的地方是泰德的邀请，泰德知道他有一个充满了精彩人类的宝箱，如果他能克服自己被罗宾拒绝的感觉，他可以将这些宝箱提供给罗宾。
If he can be generous enough to say, come, you need a tribe, I've got one.
如果他能慷慨地说，来吧，你需要一个部落，我就有一个。
I've got it for you.
我已经给你准备好了。
I can cast your life with a set of amazing friends, and he's generous enough to do that at the end of Purple Draft, and then we see the gift of that and the fact that Lily and Robin bond, and the fact that Robin sort of talks willy down and says, like, don't be insane, you have what these people are looking for.
我可以让你和一群很棒的朋友一起生活，他足够慷慨，在《紫色选秀》的最后做到了这一点，然后我们看到了这一点的天赋，以及莉莉和罗宾之间的关系，以及罗宾有点平静地说，就像，别疯了，你拥有这些人正在寻找的东西。
I love that ending.
我喜欢那个结局。
Yeah, I just felt like it was a little linear along the way.
是的，我只是觉得一路上有点线性。
Especially when we found a little bell and or whistle along the way in that storyline that could have been a little more fun, but I like plenty of it, and I really like how it ends.
特别是当我们在故事情节中发现一些小铃声和/或口哨时，本来可以更有趣一点，但我很喜欢它，而且我真的很喜欢它的结局。
And also Marshall and Lily, especially in the first season, they're metabolizing, going first.
还有马歇尔和莉莉，尤其是在第一季，他们正在新陈代谢，首先。
They are, they're metabolizing like, we're the ones who are doing this first.
他们是，他们正在新陈代谢，我们是第一个这样做的人。
We don't have any contemporaries that we can turn to and be like, what was it like in your first month of engagement?
我们没有任何同龄人可以求助，比如，你们订婚的第一个月感觉如何？
What was it like when you realized you were wedding ring repelled men in a bar or whatever?
当你意识到自己在酒吧或其他地方被结婚戒指排斥时，感觉如何？
Yeah, and this was Rebecca and I.
是的，这是丽贝卡和我。
We were the young old married couple.
我们是年轻的老夫妻。
That's what we were.
我们就是这样。
And we went through all of that and felt separate from our friends in some ways.
我们经历了这一切，并在某些方面感到与我们的朋友分离。
The thing where Marshall is home alone, studying law, like that sort of me talking of like Carter and all the late show writers, they're out doing crazy stuff.
马歇尔独自在家学习法律，就像我所说的卡特和所有已故的节目作家一样，他们出去做了疯狂的事情。
I'm in crazy stories and I'm like at a bed and breakfast and Connecticut with my wife, like with other like 60-year-olds.
我沉浸在疯狂的故事中，就像和我的妻子一起在康涅狄格州的一家住宿加早餐酒店，就像和其他 60 岁的人一样。
And we were old before our time.
而我们却提前老了。
I mean, it was fun to be old before our time.
我的意思是，在我们这个时代之前变老是很有趣的。
I was fine with that.
我对此很满意。
Every now and again, I was like, shit, I wish I could just go get McCarran Drive and like go be in Atlantic City with those guys or whatever fucking adventure they're having.
我时不时地想，妈的，我希望我能去麦卡伦大道，就像和那些家伙一起去大西洋城，或者他们正在经历的任何他妈的冒险。
So that's what this came from.
这就是这个的由来。
Speaking of Marshall home alone studying, this was for this was Marshall singing first it was the debut of Marshall.
说到马歇尔独自一人在家学习，这是因为这是马歇尔首先唱歌，这是马歇尔的首次亮相。
It's almost a musical episode.
这几乎是一个音乐剧。
It's almost like a mind a low-key musical episode because like 40% of his dialogue is song.
这几乎就像是一部低调的音乐剧，因为他的对话中有 40% 是歌曲。
I love it so much.
我非常喜欢它。
I should say that I don't recall you or Carter unless it was like a big number like you've got slapped or whatever.
我应该说，我不记得你或卡特，除非是一个很大的数字，比如你被扇了一巴掌或者其他什么。
Did you write you've you've got so after you guys wrote it.
你们写完之后你们有没有写到。
We wrote that.
我们这样写的。
You wrote that.
你写的。
But the other like, no, he did the melodies.
但另一个人说，不，他创作了旋律。
He did all the melodies.
所有的旋律都是他唱的。
He came up with what this is.
他想出了这是什么。
Yeah, I will never unhear.
是的，我永远不会听不到。
We are not loyal to be awesome.
我们并不忠诚于成为令人敬畏的人。
And we hear all the time on social media from lawyers and law students who say like, I say that five times a day.
我们经常在社交媒体上听到律师和法学院学生说，我每天都会说五次。
Like they, like lawyers in training, very much thing.
就像他们一样，就像接受培训的律师一样，非常有事情。
What's the other line, like something responsible choice for making a responsible choice for my future.
另一条线是什么，比如一些负责任的选择，为我的未来做出负责任的选择。
He's that.
他就是这样的
And by the way, that was another like we're auditioning the character because Marshall and those first couples kind of like he has to propose.
顺便说一句，这就像我们正在试镜这个角色一样，因为马歇尔和那些第一对夫妇有点像他必须求婚。
He has to be that guy has to be like the nervous guy trying to move on to a more adult chapter of life.
他必须是那种紧张的人，试图进入更成熟的人生篇章。
And this one Marshall got to show that he's this fun weirdo.
马歇尔必须证明他是一个有趣的怪人。
He's this absolute fun weirdo.
他是个绝对有趣的怪人。
He's trying to study.
他正在努力学习。
He's he's missing out on great times with his friends.
他错过了与朋友们一起度过的美好时光。
And he is singing himself like a crazy person along in the apartment and there's something so charming about it.
他在公寓里像个疯子一样唱歌，这真是太迷人了。
Seagull killed that stuff.
海鸥杀死了那东西。
Marshall has a little bit of a like puppy energy like he, we, if someone throws a ball, he goes after it.
马歇尔有一点像他一样的小狗能量，我们，如果有人扔一个球，他就会去追它。
He does.
他做到了。
Like come to Philly.
就像来到费城一样。
Okay.
好的。
I know.
我知道。
Don't go back.
别回去。
Okay.
好的。
Going around.
到处走走。
Yeah.
是的。
He really, um, he's up for, he even though he's, you know, engaged and he's trying to, you know, be responsible.
他真的，嗯，他准备好了，尽管他，你知道，订婚了，他正在努力，你知道，负责。
He's still like up for a good time.
他仍然很高兴。
Yeah.
是的。
Totally.
完全。
I love all the christened philisms in here because they make those little songs from Marshall.
我喜欢这里所有所谓的非理性，因为他们创作了马歇尔的那些小歌。
I feel like that was very much christened Phil.
我觉得这就是菲尔的名字。
That's just, there's certain things that are just very uniquely.
只是，有些东西是非常独特的。
It's only how they would say them.
这只是他们会怎么说的。
One of those songs is, and it's an act break, and they say act two break, Marshall's singing a little song at the end of act two, because he's going and turning around now.
其中一首歌是，这是一个幕间休息，他们说第二幕休息，马歇尔在第二幕结束时唱了一首小歌，因为他现在要走了，转身。
He's turned around from Philly, and I was turning around to go back to Philly, and he just ends his song by saying, destroy.
他从费城转身，我转身回到费城，他以“毁灭”结束了他的歌曲。
It is just so weird going to Philly, destroy.
去费城真是太奇怪了，毁灭。
It's just like so bizarre.
简直太奇怪了。
I don't remember.
我不记得了。
I think that was very christened Phil.
我认为这就是菲尔的洗礼。
If you look at Barney's dialogue in this episode, he's so fucking crazy in this episode.
如果你看一下巴尼在这一集中的对话，你会发现他在这一集中真是太疯狂了。
The way he speaks isn't saying, he's short, little staccato burst, he's just trying, everything is him trying to brand a new phrase, like you're saying, whether or not they've ever said it, you don't know if he's ever said this to them before, he's just pretending they say it all the time.
他说话的方式并不是在说，他很短，断断续续，他只是在尝试，一切都是他在尝试创造一个新的短语，就像你说的，无论他们是否曾经说过，你不知道他以前是否对他们说过这样的话，他只是假装他们一直在说。
But he commits to, I mean, talk about committing to the bit.
但他承诺，我的意思是，谈论承诺这一点。
Yeah.
是的。
Committing to the...
致力于...
I like the...
我喜欢...
The phone...
电话...
No, no, the phone...
不不不，电话……
The phone...
电话...
The phone is...
电话是...
is the two thing.
是两件事。
Those three photos like the point of his eyes, pointing at you, pointing at his eyes, that little three-photo montage, also a Chris and Phil joke that, so sometimes as a showrunner, you get a script into you.
这三张照片就像他的眼睛的点，指向你，指向他的眼睛，那张三张照片的小蒙太奇，也是克里斯和菲尔的一个笑话，所以有时作为一名制片人，你会得到一个剧本。
And you have this weird response where there's so many good things that you're happy because you know the rewrites not going to be very extensive, but you're also like a little bit jealous, like fuck.
你有一种奇怪的反应，有很多好东西让你很高兴，因为你知道重写不会很广泛，但你也有点嫉妒，就像他妈的。
I wish I thought of that.
我希望我能想到这一点。
Or like that's better than that.
或者这样比那样更好。
That's better than I, than I could write.
这比我写得好，比我写得好。
And like those guys, Chris and Phil, there's so many things in there that are like, you know, the lactose intolerant legendary joke.
就像克里斯和菲尔这些家伙一样，里面有很多东西就像，你知道的，乳糖不耐症的传奇笑话。
That's that's a christened full classic.
这就是所谓的完整经典。
It's very funny after the show ended like 10 years out, you know, sometimes recently we got a call from Entertainment Weekly Carter and I did.
这部剧结束十年后，这很有趣，你知道，最近有时我们接到《娱乐周刊卡特》的电话，我也接到了。
They're like, we wanted to talk to you guys as showiners of how I met your mother.
他们就像是，我们想和你们聊聊我是如何认识你们母亲的。
We're doing this like top 50 best TV catchphrases or best lines on a series.
我们这样做就像评选前 50 名最佳电视流行语或电视剧中的最佳台词一样。
I'm like, oh, don't mind if I do.
我想，哦，如果我这样做的话不要介意。
That's straight in my tie here.
就在我的领带上。
Maybe they'll put a photo of us.
也许他们会贴一张我们的照片。
I wonder which one of our gems that we wrote Entertainment Weekly wants to highlight.
我想知道我们撰写的《娱乐周刊》想要强调哪一项瑰宝。
And they're like, yeah, we already talked to christened Phil because it's their line, but we just want a little background from you too.
他们就像，是的，我们已经和受洗的菲尔谈过了，因为这是他们的台词，但我们也只是想从你那里了解一些背景知识。
And we're like, how did you want to buy your Christmas clothes?
我们问，你想怎么买圣诞衣服？
So you and you and Carter obviously were the main writers on the first two episodes.
所以你、你和卡特显然是前两集的主要编剧。
Yeah.
是的。
And then you get this, you get a writer, you get a writers room together like, how much did you crack the story of sweet taste of liberty and then hand it to Chris and Phil?
然后你得到了这个，你得到了一个作家，你得到了一个作家房间，就像，你破解了多少自由甜蜜滋味的故事，然后把它交给克里斯和菲尔？
Or did they say, let's write a Barney cartoon and they came back with that?
或者他们说，让我们写一部巴尼漫画，然后他们就回来了？
They were part of cracking it, but they were a very strong voice of Barney cartoon.
他们是破解这个问题的一部分，但他们是巴尼卡通的一个非常强烈的声音。
We did this hour long romcom, a very sweet, very hard felt.
我们演了一个小时的浪漫喜剧，一种非常甜蜜又非常艰难的感觉。
we need to be.
我们需要这样做。
They wanted to take over and make it like a fun cartoon and that idea of you going to the airport.
他们想把它变成一部有趣的卡通片，以及你去机场的想法。
I got to pick someone up at the airport, the security cam montage, the fact that they're getting on airplanes.
我要去机场接人，安全摄像头蒙太奇，他们要上飞机的事实。
They had a great like bravado and fearlessness to like let's just take swings.
他们有一种伟大的虚张声势和无畏精神，喜欢让我们大胆行动。
And I just think that comes from that animation brain incentive in some way.
我只是认为这在某种程度上来自于动画大脑的激励。
So did you guys, did the writers room come up with like, Barney's picking up girls at the airport, like picking someone up at the airport, like going to Philly with those those girls and finding out they date Philadelphia Eagles or whatever, like, I think it was one thing led to another.
你们呢，编剧室有没有想到，巴尼在机场接女孩，就像在机场接人，就像和那些女孩一起去费城，发现她们约会费城老鹰队或者其他什么，就像，我认为这是一件事导致了另一件事。
I think we had the pun of picking up somebody at the airport.
我想我们有去机场接人的双关语。
We liked that.
我们喜欢这样。
And that brought us to the airport and you just keep yes ending it.
这把我们带到了机场，你只要继续说“是”就结束了。
Then it became like, what if they do wind up on a plane and flying to a different city?
然后就变成了，如果他们最终乘坐飞机飞往另一个城市怎么办？
And like just pushing it and pushing it and pushing it.
就像只是推它、推它、推它。
And I feel like those guys were very good at like, don't be afraid.
我觉得那些人非常擅长，不要害怕。
This one's going to be a road trip movie.
这将是一部公路旅行电影。
We're just going to do it.
我们只是去做而已。
They're just there.
他们就在那里。
And I have that idea of having, like in the Liberty Bell, like we have to make it a legendary I mean, a lot of that was from Chris and Phil, and I'm forever grateful for it, because it did help deepen and define Barney.
我有这样的想法，就像在自由钟一样，我们必须使它成为一个传奇，我的意思是，其中很多都来自克里斯和菲尔，我永远对此感激不已，因为它确实有助于加深和定义巴尼。
And it showed you like some of these episodes are just gonna be like a crazy trip to the circus.
它向你展示了其中一些剧集就像一次疯狂的马戏团之旅。
Like they're not all gonna be like super-filled.
就像他们不会都超级饱一样。
I have a writing question.
我有一个写作问题。
Obviously it's season one.
显然这是第一季。
So everything you're doing is defining future characters, but you know, on other, on even in the shows we loved on, on, on, Mashed on Cheers, plots didn't threaten to redefine characters, right?
所以你所做的一切都是在定义未来的角色，但你知道，在其他方面，甚至在我们喜欢的节目中，在《欢呼雀跃》中，情节并没有威胁到重新定义角色，对吧？
Even from episode one, everyone sort of set, and then it's like, what high jinks are they getting into?
即使从第一集开始，每个人都已经准备好了，然后就会想，他们到底在搞什么恶作剧？
But you've got to make big decisions because you have an end game in sight and you've also decided this is gonna be a different kind of show.
但你必须做出重大决定，因为你已经看到了结局，而且你也决定这将是一场不同类型的演出。
So you start off with ultimate, Ted Romantic, looking for the one and kind of maybe finds it.
所以你从终极的 Ted Romantic 开始，寻找那个，也许会找到它。
And now you have to, I don't know, you're gonna switch to Ted's gonna start dating the co-check girl, the crossing guard you're going to send Ted off on smaller adventures and what goes into your far-thinking mind as you're writing these early plots.
现在你必须这样做，我不知道，你要切换到泰德开始和副检查女孩约会，你要派泰德去进行较小的冒险的路边警卫，以及当你写这些早期情节时，你的远见卓识会发生什么。
I remember thinking for a while and I think wrongly that we had to make episode three dealing with like how is Ted at integrating Robin into the group and I think in the end it was a good decision not to do that.
我记得想了一会儿，我认为我们必须让第三集处理泰德如何将罗宾融入团队的问题，我认为这是错误的，我认为最终不这样做是一个很好的决定。
It was like Ted invited Robin and the group.
这就像泰德邀请罗宾和他的团队一样。
She's bonding with Lily, let him let Ted.
她和莉莉关系很好，让他让特德吧。
Don't make it about Ted and Robin.
别把事情扯到泰德和罗宾身上。
This one is something else.
这是另一回事。
And we knew we'd get to more of Ted and Robin later.
我们知道稍后我们会更多地了解泰德和罗宾。
I remember feeling like wanting to plant the seed of Lily's insecurity about getting engaged, like just have a little seed planted about, you know, this thing where she's like, I'm invisible now that I have this ring, not that she wants to go hook up with some other guy in the Marshall, but it's just what Josh said earlier.
我记得我想种下莉莉对订婚的不安全感的种子，就像种下一颗小小的种子，你知道，她就像是，我现在有了这枚戒指，我就隐形了，并不是说她想和马歇尔的其他男人勾搭，但这正是乔什之前说的。
It's like the, my identity has shifted in some way.
就像，我的身份在某种程度上发生了变化。
A door has closed.
一扇门已经关闭。
I'm heading towards a kind of adulthood and like the cement drying on my life a little bit.
我正走向成年，喜欢生活中的水泥逐渐干燥。
We knew we wanted to plant seeds that Marsle and Lily as stable as they seem, they would, they're still young, they're still might be turbulence in their journey towards their wedding day.
我们知道我们想要播下种子，让马塞尔和莉莉像看起来一样稳定，他们会的，他们还年轻，他们在婚礼的旅程中仍然可能会经历动荡。
We knew we wanted to plant that seed and we knew we wanted to sort of show that Ted wasn't going to stop trying to go have crazy adventures just because he was like smitten with Robbins.
我们知道我们想播下这颗种子，我们知道我们想表明泰德不会仅仅因为迷上了罗宾斯就停止尝试疯狂的冒险。
We wanted to make those two sales, Barney and Ted going out on the town was going to be a speed of the show.
我们想要完成这两笔销售，巴尼和特德去镇上将成为展会的一个速度。
So I feel like we were doing long-term planning here.
所以我觉得我们正在这里做长期规划。
We were kind of planting a little something, a little bit of turbulence for Lily, even though it's late and silly in this episode, it's there.
我们有点为莉莉种下了一些东西，一点点动荡，尽管在这一集里有点晚了而且很愚蠢，但它就在那里。
And Ted's wrestling was whether Barney's going to help get him where he needs to go.
特德的难题是巴尼是否会帮助他到达他需要去的地方。
Do I really want to be dragged to Philadelphia for no reason to hang out with two girls and boyfriends?
我真的想无缘无故地被拖到费城和两个女孩和男朋友一起出去玩吗？
So I think like, ending that episode, but Ted saying, future Ted saying, it was good that I hung out with Barney.
所以我想，结束那一集，但特德说，未来的特德说，我和巴尼一起出去玩很好。
I could get stuck in Russ and Barney could bust me out of them, and acknowledging that is kind of saying the audience like, you're going to see that story.
我可能会被困在拉斯中，而巴尼可能会把我从他们中救出来，承认这一点就相当于在说观众喜欢，你会看到这个故事。
They're going to have fun adventures on this show.
他们将在这个节目中经历有趣的冒险。
And now commercials.
现在是广告。
There was a time when I would ignore, or maybe not even notice, when my sheets started slipping off the corners, or pilling, or when my pillows weren't quite as supportive as I wanted them to be.
曾经有一段时间，当我的床单开始从角落滑落或起球，或者当我的枕头不像我希望的那样支撑时，我会忽略，或者甚至没有注意到。
My wife, however, has always noticed this sort of thing.
然而，我的妻子总是注意到这种事情。
But now that we've got a baby waking up at, you know, various times, every moment of sleep has become invaluable, and I am so delighted that Bull and Branch sent us some of the The comfiest sheets that I have ever had the pleasure to sleep upon, their organic cotton bedding, is designed for deep uninterrupted rest, which is what we're getting.
但现在我们有了一个宝宝，你知道，在不同的时间醒来，每时每刻的睡眠都变得非常宝贵，我很高兴 Bull 和 Branch 给我们送来了一些我睡过的最舒适的床单，他们的有机棉床上用品，专为深度不间断的休息而设计，这就是我们所得到的。
The sheets are incredibly soft, they're breathable, and it's a total game-changer for our energy levels, especially with this young, occasionally sleeping baby we have now.
这些床单非常柔软，透气，它完全改变了我们的能量水平，尤其是对于我们现在这个偶尔睡觉的小婴儿来说。
This is the kind of comfort we can't afford to compromise anymore.
这是我们不能再妥协的舒适感。
your sleep with Bowling Branch.
你和保龄球馆一起睡觉。
Get 15% off your first order plus free shipping at BowlingBranch.com slash your mother with code your mother.
在 BowlingBranch.com 首次订购可享受 15% 折扣，并免运费，使用代码 your mother 砍掉你的母亲。
That's Bowling Branch, B-O-L-L-A-N-D branch.com slash your mother.
那是保龄球分行，B-O-L-L-A-N-D 分行.com 砍你妈妈。
Code your mother to unlock 15% off exclusion supply.
给你妈妈编码即可解锁 15% 的排除供应折扣。
I could talk for hours about every single episode of how I met your mother.
我可以谈论几个小时关于我如何遇见你母亲的每一件事。
And we do!
我们做到了！
But when it comes to my own health, I used to be pretty clueless.
但当谈到我自己的健康时，我却一无所知。
I'd shrug off low energy, or a fitness plateau is just stress, basically guessing about what my body actually needed.
我会摆脱低能量，或者健身平台只是压力，基本上猜测我的身体实际需要什么。
But you shouldn't guess when it comes to your health.
但当涉及到您的健康时，您不应该猜测。
Instead, you should get the real data that supports your wellness with lab core on-demand health testing.
相反，您应该通过实验室核心按需健康测试来获取支持您健康的真实数据。
On the website, you can choose from a suite of more than 100 health tests, including micronutrient allergy testosterone, fitness, sexual wellness, and more, all available to purchase without a doctor's appointment.
在该网站上，您可以从 100 多种健康测试中进行选择，包括微量营养素过敏、睾酮、健身、性健康等，所有这些都可以在无需医生预约的情况下购买。
Just purchase a test online, then visit a local lab core location to have your sample collected.
只需在线购买测试，然后访问当地实验室核心地点即可收集样本。
It's so simple.
就是这么简单。
Within days, you'll have accurate results that are easy to understand from a lab doctor's trust.
几天之内，您将获得实验室医生信任的易于理解的准确结果。
To start your journey, visit ondemand.labcore.com slash mother, and use code mother to save up to 15% on select tests.
要开始您的旅程，请访问 ondemand.labcore.com slim mother，并使用 code mother 在特定测试中节省高达 15% 的费用。
That's ondemand.labcore.com slash mother and use code mother.
这就是 ondemand.labcore.com 斜线母亲和使用代码母亲。
Know yourself.
了解你自己。
End of commercials back to show.
广告结束返回放映。
I also thought, so this was something, Jordan and I were talking about she didn't do a recording but she said if you want to say that we talked about this thing but something that jumped out to both of us was there's a spiritual principle that we talk about all the time there's three forces in the universe there's the creation the force of creation the force of maintenance and the force of destruction right and there are these dynamic three forces they're always going and if you keep the creation force at the front of your life.
我也想，所以这是一件事，乔丹和我正在谈论她没有录音，但她说，如果你想说我们谈论了这件事，但我们俩都跳出来了，那就是我们一直在谈论的一个精神原则，宇宙中存在三种力量，那就是创造、创造的力量、维持的力量和毁灭的力量，这三种动态的力量它们总是会发生的，如果你把创造的力量放在你生活的前面。
That means risk taking chances, stepping into the unknown, trying new things, going new places, challenging yourself.
这意味着冒险、踏入未知、尝试新事物、去新地方、挑战自己。
Then in the second place is maintenance where things that are working that you want to keep in your life.
其次是维护，即您希望将那些正在工作的东西保留在您的生活中。
But it has to be in the second position.
但它必须处于第二位置。
And then naturally, the things that are irrelevant to your life go away.
然后自然地，与你的生活无关的事情就会消失。
The destruction operator takes care of all those.
销毁操作员负责处理所有这些事情。
However, if you elevate maintenance into the first position, Okay, when you say, no, no, I just want things to stay the same.
然而，如果你把维护提升到第一位，好吧，当你说，不，不，我只是希望事情保持不变。
I don't want to rock the boat.
我不想惹事生非。
I don't want anything new in treating my life.
我不想要任何新的东西来对待我的生活。
It's all about familiarity and routine.
这一切都与熟悉和常规有关。
And you bump this creation operator down to number two.
然后你把这个创建操作符降到了第二位。
It provokes the destruction.
它引发了破坏。
So it's like the universe wants you back in the unknown and the juicy good novel stuff, right?
所以这就好像宇宙希望你回到未知的、有趣的小说中，对吧？
That's a good theory.
这是一个很好的理论。
So if you look at your life and you see, oh my God, there's destruction everywhere.
所以如果你审视自己的生活，你会发现，天啊，到处都是毁灭。
should look and say, have I been living in too much in maintenance?
应该看看并说，我是否生活在太多的维护中？
Have I not been moving forward?
难道我就没有一直往前走吗？
Right?
正确的？
So we've turned to each other and we're like, Barney is actually the force of creation in this.
所以我们互相求助，我们想，巴尼实际上是这方面的创造力量。
And Ted keeps saying, especially at the beginning, I just want to be at my same bar with my same friends and my same drink.
特德一直说，尤其是在开始的时候，我只想在同一个酒吧里和我同样的朋友一起喝同样的酒。
Like he's really arguing for a life of maintenance and familiarity and regularity.
就好像他真正主张过一种维护、熟悉和规律的生活。
And there's something about Barney, he's He's not quite the devil, he's actually like, he's trying to shake the dust off of Ted and saying like, your life will be better if you go on adventures with me.
巴尼有一些东西，他并不完全是魔鬼，他实际上就像，他试图抖落泰德身上的灰尘，然后说，如果你和我一起去冒险，你的生活会更好。
Absolutely.
绝对地。
That's a great way to look at this, like chaos as a creative force here.
这是一个很好的看待这个问题的方式，就像混乱是这里的创造力一样。
Barney is chaos as a creative force and it is interesting because I think we could have written this better.
巴尼是一种混乱的创造力，这很有趣，因为我认为我们可以写得更好。
I love that I'm listening regrets in this episode.
我喜欢在这一集里听到遗憾。
It's a really good episode, but I think we could have even made clearer because it's in there.
这是一个非常好的剧集，但我认为我们甚至可以说得更清楚，因为它就在那里。
I think Ted is saying I just want to be in my same bar because he just, he didn't land the girl in episode two, right?
我想特德是在说我只想呆在同一个酒吧，因为他在第二集中没有找到那个女孩，对吧？
He didn't get Robin.
他没有得到罗宾。
He took a big risk.
他冒了很大的风险。
He took a big risk and it didn't pay off.
他冒了很大的风险，但没有得到回报。
So he wants to retreat to that bar and he goes, well, Robin walked into that bar.
所以他想撤退到那个酒吧，然后他说，好吧，罗宾走进了那个酒吧。
She was almost the one.
她几乎就是那个人了。
Maybe it'll happen again.
也许它会再次发生。
If I sit in this bar long enough, she'll walk in.
如果我在这家酒吧坐得够久，她就会走进来。
It's almost that same thing of the slutty pumpkin, right?
这和放荡的南瓜几乎是一样的，对吧？
Ted sitting up on top of the roof.
特德坐在屋顶上。
Like, she's going to come back and And he wants, and it is like, I just want to, I want stasis.
就像，她会回来，而他想要，就像，我只是想要，我想要停滞。
I want maintenance.
我要维护。
And that's not how things get created in the world.
世界上的事物并不是这样创造的。
And that's, yeah, Barney helps him break out of that.
是的，巴尼帮助他摆脱了困境。
But I wish we had said something like, spoke into the idea that because Ted was a little bruised by, you know, Robin Natsang, let's be together, that that's part of his retreating to the bar, like kind of a troll into the shell.
但我希望我们能说一些类似的话，谈到这样的想法，因为泰德被罗宾·纳桑（Robin Natsang）弄伤了一点，让我们在一起吧，这是他撤退到酒吧的一部分，就像一个巨魔进入了壳里。
I think we could have made that sale.
我认为我们本可以完成这笔交易。
Well, I think that's what it was.
嗯，我想就是这样。
You made Barney's subtext explicit, but you don't make Ted's explicit.
你让巴尼的潜台词变得明确，但你没有让特德的潜台词变得明确。
Yeah, can we get back into the episode?
是啊，我们能回到正剧吗？
We could add that.
我们可以补充一点。
So in some ways, maybe that would have helped me feel less like Ted was a wet blanket and more like, no, I'm blicking my wounds, like my nerve endings got exposed and I got, I got cinched, you know?
所以在某些方面，也许这会让我感觉不像特德是一条湿毯子，而更像是，不，我正在擦拭我的伤口，就像我的神经末梢暴露了一样，我得到了，我被收紧了，你知道吗？
Yeah, I think that's what it was, but we didn't quite say it enough, honestly.
是的，我认为就是这样，但老实说，我们说得还不够。
So I'm gonna be giving notes each week on what I've been thinking of that.
所以我每周都会记录我的想法。
I don't think I was thinking of that.
我想我没有想到这一点。
I wish I had been thinking that, you know, I think that would have, you know what would have made you think that if we fucking wrote it that way.
我希望我一直在想，你知道，我想如果我们他妈的那样写的话，你知道什么会让你这么想。
I could only work with what I got.
我只能用我所拥有的来工作。
But that's that.
但就是这样。
I adore this episode and I think probably the reason we didn't make the linger too much on that.
我很喜欢这一集，我想这可能是我们没有在这一集上停留太多的原因。
We might have gotten some notes of like, it can't just be the Ted is hung up on Robin show.
我们可能会收到一些类似这样的注释，这不仅仅是泰德挂在罗宾的节目上。
It has to be fun, right?
它一定很有趣，对吧？
It has to be like a fun adventurous, get them out on the town and I think we were very like hung up on that.
这必须像一次有趣的冒险，让他们到城里去，我想我们对此非常着迷。
I do remember we were getting some notes from the studio network like, all right, show some fun speeds, your sandwich between king of queens and two and a half men, get the boys out on the town trying to get laid.
我确实记得我们从演播室网络收到了一些笔记，比如，好吧，展示一些有趣的速度，你的皇后国王和两个半男人之间的三明治，让男孩们去城里尝试上床。
And also they were, I think they were thinking about if someone just tunes in and they haven't seen the first two episodes, is there, because I know there was a debate always about standalone versus, I think, kind of episodic, saga's.
而且他们也在考虑，如果有人只是收看，但他们还没有看过前两集，是不是就在那里，因为我知道一直存在关于独立与我认为是情节式传奇的争论。
So this is a pretty standalone episode, like you could just stumble upon this show in 2005 October, and you could watch it and be delighted because it presents its story and it wraps it up in 22 minutes, you know.
所以这是一个非常独立的剧集，就像你在 2005 年 10 月偶然发现这个节目一样，你可以观看它并感到高兴，因为它呈现了它的故事，并且在 22 分钟内结束了它，你知道。
That was the mission.
这就是使命。
That was the mission of this episode and it was sort of like almost involuntarily the mission because I think the suit in the network were like great hour-long, great two-parter.
这就是这一集的使命，这有点像几乎不由自主地完成的使命，因为我认为网络中的诉讼就像一个小时的精彩两方。
Now do you want that's like a little chocolate and a box of chocolates and that's how all the CBS had comes worth the time for better or second.
现在你想要一点巧克力和一盒巧克力吗？这就是哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS）的所有内容值得花时间去更好或其次的原因。
I'm not even saying it's a bad thing.
我什至不是说这是一件坏事。
That's just what they did on CBS at that time and we needed to do some of of that to fit in.
这正是他们当时在 CBS 所做的，我们需要做一些事情来适应。
But what we love to do was to be more serialized.
但我们喜欢做的是更加系列化。
How do we have the courage to make this one a little more serialized at the beginning?
我们如何有勇气在一开始就把这个系列化一点呢？
I think we would have talked more about Ted bruised and licking his wounds.
我想我们会更多地谈论泰德的瘀伤和舔伤口。
But we were just like, we were given the notes, like, shoot these guys out of a cannon on a fun cartoon.
但我们就像，我们得到了笔记，比如，在一部有趣的卡通片中把这些家伙从大炮中射出来。
And in a way that is what's great about the episode.
从某种程度上来说，这就是这一集的精彩之处。
So I don't really regret it.
所以我真的不后悔。
Can I ask real quick, where did you get the, where did the untucked shirt, uh, bit come from?
我能快速问一下，你从哪里得到的，那件没塞进裤子里的衬衫，呃，一点是从哪里来的？
I don't know where that came from.
我不知道那是从哪里来的。
Well, you know what I think it was.
嗯，你知道我的想法是什么。
I think I think for the first two episodes, I had some untucked shirts going.
我想我认为在前两集中，我有一些衬衫没塞进去。
You had untucked shirts?
你衬衫没塞进裤腰吗？
So it was already established as a look, right?
所以它的外观已经确定了，对吧？
It was a look.
这是一个眼神。
Yeah, and it's, and Barney hates, he's like tucked the shirt.
是的，巴尼讨厌的是，他喜欢把衬衫塞进裤子里。
Like, I think it was just Barney, like, you're unsewed, you're not in his suit.
就像，我认为这只是巴尼，就像，你没有缝衣服，你没有穿着他的西装。
That's bad enough.
这已经够糟糕的了。
But if you're gonna have a blazer on a shirt, tuck in the goddamn shirt.
但如果你想在衬衫上穿一件西装外套，就把那该死的衬衫塞进去。
I think it was just, Barney just wants Ted to do what he says.
我认为巴尼只是希望泰德按他说的去做。
That's his main drive.
这是他的主要动力。
And somebody's in all of the first three episodes, that's his main drive, maybe more than getting laid.
前三集中都有一个人，这是他的主要动力，也许不仅仅是上床。
I mean, again, they do not hook up in this episode.
我的意思是，他们在这一集里并没有勾搭。
It's sort of delightful, because I think it really proves that thing of like, Barney and Ted, Barney and Ted do not get with ladies, so they don't look up together.
这有点令人愉快，因为我认为这确实证明了巴尼和泰德，巴尼和泰德不喜欢女人，所以他们不会一起抬头。
Wait a minute.
等一下。
I realize how I said that.
我意识到我是怎么说的。
Spoilers, Barney and Ted get together at the end of season one.
剧透一下，巴尼和泰德在第一季结束时聚在一起。
But Barney and Ted do not succeed either of them and getting the girl in this episode.
但巴尼和泰德在这一集里都没有成功得到那个女孩。
And I kind of love the seeds that plants have just how, like, Barney really doesn't, he does not have nearly the success rate.
我有点喜欢植物的种子，但巴尼真的没有，他几乎没有成功率。
Yeah.
是的。
If you really look at a lot of these episodes, like he's really just, there's a lot of 83% lying happening here.
如果你真的看很多这样的情节，就像他真的很公正一样，有很多 83% 的谎言发生在这里。
And I think also part of Barney's eternal fascination with Ted is he won't obey him.
我认为巴尼对泰德永远着迷的部分原因是他不会服从他。
Like he won't give him what he wants.
就像他不会给他他想要的一样。
He doesn't let him change his life.
他不允许他改变自己的生活。
I mean, he doesn't incrementally, but there's something, you know, it's kind of like Barney's like a lot of seducers like love the chase, but they don't like it when someone turns around and says, okay, you know, it's really true.
我的意思是，他并没有逐渐增加，但有一些东西，你知道，有点像巴尼，就像很多诱惑者喜欢追逐，但他们不喜欢有人转过身来说，好吧，你知道，这真的是真的。
He is, he is trying to cast a sort of a thrall over Ted in these episodes much more than overwhelming.
他是的，他试图在这些剧集中对泰德施加一种奴役，而不仅仅是压倒性的。
And in the end, he doesn't care.
最后，他不在乎。
He's like, all right, we're not getting laid tonight, but we're going to do something legendary.
他说，好吧，我们今晚不会上床，但我们要做一些传奇般的事情。
We're going to give it and make it a story we'll always tell.
我们将赋予它并使其成为我们永远讲述的故事。
And he does, he does it.
他做到了，他做到了。
He does that magic trick.
他会表演那个魔术。
He's that friend.
他就是那个朋友。
And I think we all have friends like this where like we never would have had that story without that friend.
我想我们都有这样的朋友，如果没有那个朋友，我们永远不会有这样的故事。
And that is a gift and life is short.
这是一份礼物，而生命是短暂的。
And you end up years and years later, what are the stories you remember?
多年以后，你还记得哪些故事？
What are the stories you're going to tell?
你要讲什么故事？
And Barney gives you that.
巴尼给了你这个。
Barney gives you that.
I would like to say to any of our listeners, if you have licked the Liberty Bell, or if you're a security guard at the Liberty Bell and you've had to stop people or knowing what they're doing, you'll let them get away with it from licking the Liberty Bell.
我想对我们的任何一位听众说，如果你舔过自由钟，或者如果你是自由钟的保安，你必须阻止人们或知道他们在做什么，你会让他们摆脱舔自由钟的惩罚。
We'd like to hear from you.
我们希望收到您的来信。
We'd like to hear what your experience was with that.
我们想听听您对此的体验。
We're not endorsing or encouraging.
我们并不赞同或鼓励。
Not endorsing it.
不赞同。
Don't endorsing it.
不予赞同。
But if you've already done it and you took a picture of it, we would like to see it.
但如果您已经完成并拍了照片，我们很想看看。
Don't go away.
别走开。
It's if you did it.
就是如果你做到了。
Yeah.
是的。
Add how we made your add how I was the thing.
添加我们如何让您添加我是如何的事情。
How we made your mother.
我们如何造就了你的母亲。
Dot com.
.com.
And how we made your mother on Instagram.
以及我们如何在 Instagram 上塑造你的母亲。
How I made another account and go to contact.
我如何创建另一个帐户并去联系。
Yeah.
是的。
Right.
正确的。
But it's absolutely.
但这是绝对的。
I've already been, my mind's already been blown in these first two episodes about Barney in particular.
我已经，尤其是关于巴尼的前两集已经让我大吃一惊。
I have the good fortune of a terrible memory.
我很幸运，记忆力很差。
So I am watching this show almost new.
所以我几乎是全新观看这个节目。
I have forgotten quite a bit along the way.
一路上我已经忘记了很多。
And the idea of Barney being, I'm going to compare it as I will do several times to Eyes Wide Shut, to Stanley Gerber.
至于巴尼的想法，我将把它与《大开眼戒》和斯坦利·格伯进行多次比较。
So there's a scene at the end of Eyes Wide Shot where Sidney Pollock explains everything to Tom Cruise that just happened in this movie.
所以在《大开眼界》的结尾有一个场景，西德尼·波洛克向汤姆·克鲁斯解释了这部电影中刚刚发生的一切。
And people complain about this as you're just telling him or at least the end.
人们抱怨这一点，因为你只是告诉他或者至少是结局。
And it was years later that's a writer pointed out, you don't have to believe what he's saying.
多年后，一位作家指出，你不必相信他说的话。
Maybe he's lying the whole time.
也许他一直在撒谎。
Right.
正确的。
And that gives you a whole new, oh, right.
这给了你一个全新的，哦，对了。
You've made a big assumption, but hold on.
你已经做了一个很大的假设，但请坚持下去。
Same thing with Barney.
巴尼也是如此。
I think that, and maybe it's my bad memory.
我是这么想的，也许是我记性不好。
The idea that he's making a lot of his stories up, or that he's not the lethario and he hasn't been with that many women, it's kind of new in my head right now and maybe I'm just forgetting things that I should have known.
他编造了很多故事，或者他不是一个麻木不仁的人，他也没有和那么多女人在一起，这在我的脑海里现在有点新鲜，也许我只是忘记了我应该知道的事情。
When you were writing him, when you were first creating him, I know he's based on some people that you knew, what was the essence of it?
当你写他的时候，当你第一次创造他的时候，我知道他是基于你认识的一些人，它的本质是什么？
We need this kind of wild guy character who's going to all be about the hunt.
我们需要这种狂野的家伙角色，他的一切都是为了狩猎。
Is it we need a kind of broken soul who's covering it with it was that it was wanting to see the broken soul beneath toxic masculinity.
我们是否需要一种破碎的灵魂来覆盖它，因为它想看到有毒的男性气质下破碎的灵魂。
It was wanting to parody toxic masculinity and then humanize it by showing all over the broken parts underneath and then you do nine seasons of it and along the way sometimes it just becomes like let's do a funny joke about Barney trying to get laid and you kind of lose some of that at moments.
它想要模仿有毒的男子气概，然后通过展示下面所有破碎的部分来将其人性化，然后你做了九季，一路上有时它就像让我们开一个关于巴尼试图上床的有趣笑话，你有时会失去一些。
But I think the through line for me and why why I don't look at it like oh, we couldn't get away with that today, it always, the intention was always, let's show how broken this guy is underneath the suit and then show hints of him trying to grow and heal throughout the series and end him up somewhere different than he started.
但我认为对我来说，为什么我不这样看待它，哦，我们今天无法摆脱这一点，它总是，意图总是，让我们展示这个家伙在宇航服下面有多么破碎，然后展示他在整个系列中试图成长和治愈的暗示，并最终让他到达与开始时不同的地方。
And I also think whatever, whether you're a guy who's obsessed with getting laid and meeting women and not that successful at it or you're part of like pickup culture and you actually are successful with it, both of them carry a lot of pain underneath them.
我还认为，无论如何，无论你是一个痴迷于上床和结识女性但在这方面不太成功的男人，还是你属于把妹文化的一部分，但你实际上在这方面取得了成功，他们两人的内心都承受着很多痛苦。
They do.
他们确实这么做了。
Like, you don't behave that way single-mindedly and almost psychotically if you're not feeling some sort of great absence at the center of your heart.
就像，如果你的内心没有感受到某种巨大的缺席，你就不会一心一意地、近乎精神病地那样行事。
I know for 100%, it's like an addiction, it's like filling a hole, it really is like a missing piece in somebody and I always thought, that's how I look at Barney and that's why I have such, I've had him so endearing at these early episodes because I see that spark, I see that initial idea in him in these episodes and I hope that.
我百分百知道，这就像一种瘾，就像填补一个洞，它真的就像某人身上缺失的一块，我一直想，这就是我对巴尼的看法，这就是为什么我有这样的，我让他在这些早期剧集中如此可爱，因为我看到了火花，我在这些剧集中看到了他最初的想法，我希望如此。
One of the fascinating, I think, kind of tensions in the show is I think you and Carter would say, no, we always saw him as kind of sad and broken, but trying, and he doesn't get laid nearly as much as he claims to, whereas I think Neil would disagree with you.
我认为，节目中令人着迷的紧张气氛之一是我认为你和卡特会说，不，我们总是认为他有点悲伤和破碎，但在努力，而且他并没有像他声称的那样经常上床，而我认为尼尔会不同意你的观点。
I think Neil thought, Neil played him as if he was getting laid every night.
我想尼尔想，尼尔把他打得好像他每天晚上都上床一样。
Yeah.
是的。
I think that's some of the interesting tension of the character.
我认为这就是这个角色的一些有趣的张力。
Well, it's funny because Neil, I mean, it was like a superhero outfit.
嗯，这很有趣，因为尼尔，我的意思是，它就像超级英雄的服装。
Neil had to put on every week, right?
尼尔每周都必须穿上，对吗？
It was Batman, it was Iron Man.
这是蝙蝠侠，这是钢铁侠。
He had to put this on and be that superhero and perform that and believe his own stories.
他必须穿上它，成为那个超级英雄，表演它，并相信自己的故事。
And then those moments where we did have him step out of that and show some other side, they were very effective because of how much he had committed to the first thing.
然后，我们确实让他走出困境并展现出另一面的那些时刻，它们非常有效，因为他对第一件事做出了巨大的承诺。
And I always found myself more jealous of the other characters because I thought they all had costumes that I wasn't allowed to wear.
我总是发现自己更嫉妒其他角色，因为我认为他们都穿着我不被允许穿的服装。
Yeah, like I thought they all had some armor up around them that allowed them to, I don't know, float through the world of how I met your mother in a less just vulnerable way.
是的，就像我以为他们周围都有一些盔甲，让他们能够，我不知道，以一种不那么脆弱的方式漂浮在我遇见你母亲的世界中。
I mean, everyone had their vulnerable moments to be sure.
我的意思是，每个人都有脆弱的时刻。
I'm not taking that away from anyone, but Ted just, he didn't have that armor.
我不会把它从任何人身上夺走，但特德只是，他没有那件盔甲。
I had to kind of have my nerve endings exposed for nine years.
我的神经末梢必须暴露九年。
Yeah, you were on your own a lot of the time because Marshall had Lily and that meant sort of Segal had handing into bond with.
是的，很多时候你都是独自一人，因为马​​歇尔有莉莉，这意味着西格尔已经与他建立了联系。
Robin was supposed to be this thing.
罗宾本来就是这样的。
Ted couldn't have, right?
特德不可能有，对吧？
You couldn't fully connect with that character.
你无法完全与那个角色建立联系。
Those two characters weren't gonna get together right away.
这两个角色不会立即聚在一起。
And Barney's inside this Darth Vader outfit.
巴尼穿着这身达斯·维德服装。
And Ted is a little bit like on his own little island.
特德有点像在他自己的小岛上。
Well, it's almost like everybody, but no one likes first dates.
嗯，几乎每个人都一样，但没有人喜欢第一次约会。
I mean, most of them are bad.
我的意思是，他们中的大多数都很糟糕。
And Ted had hundreds, you know?
特德有数百个，你知道吗？
Like there is a feeling that he couldn't settle.
好像有一种无法平复的感觉。
He couldn't land the plane of what he most wanted.
他无法让他最想要的飞机降落。
But I think also, you know, much like Barney, like everyone, you know, when I was editing my first movie, I worked with this great editor, Michael Miller, for both my movies, and he used to say movies and television are very different for this one reason.
但我也认为，你知道，就像巴尼一样，就像每个人一样，你知道，当我剪辑我的第一部电影时，我与这位伟大的剪辑师迈克尔·米勒一起工作了我的两部电影，他曾经说过，由于这个原因，电影和电视非常不同。
In movies, you have to show transformation in 90 minutes or two hours, because that's the whole time you have allotted.
在电影中，你必须在 90 分钟或两个小时内展现转变，因为那是你分配的全部时间。
In TV, if you're gonna change them at all, it's so incremental, because you're trying to keep people watching and you're kind of hitting the same thing.
在电视领域，如果你要改变它们，那是渐进式的，因为你试图让人们继续观看，但你却在做同样的事情。
Now, I think you guys split the difference on this really well in terms of letting characters evolve over nine years, but still they would come back to what was in their DNA pretty regularly.
现在，我认为你们在让角色在九年的时间里进化方面很好地区分了这一点，但他们仍然会定期回到他们的 DNA 中。
Yeah, yeah, that's right.
是啊是啊，没错。
That was always the balancing act.
这始终是一种平衡行为。
That was always, we don't want to be stuck in the same route.
一直如此，我们不想陷入同一条道路。
We want to change them up, but they have to have a through line and Ted changed season to season, but there were moments where, yeah, there were so many moments where Ted had to be the vulnerable one where you had to sort of put your heart out there to get sort of stomped on.
我们想要改变他们，但他们必须有一条贯穿路线，特德在一个又一个赛季都在改变，但有些时候，是的，有很多时候，特德必须成为脆弱的人，你必须把你的心放在那里，才能被踩在脚下。
We've talked about this and we will talk about this more, but the first two seasons, I think I really was looking for how am I similar to this guy.
我们已经讨论过这个问题，我们还会更多地讨论这个问题，但是前两个赛季，我想我真的在寻找我和这个人有什么相似之处。
And then at some point, I just went off in different directions and I thought, no, that's not even psychologically helpful anymore.
然后在某个时候，我只是朝着不同的方向前进，我想，不，这在心理上不再有帮助了。
I'm just gonna play him as a character and I didn't take it as personally.
我只是把他当作一个角色来扮演，我并没有把他当作是针对我个人的。
I didn't, you know, and so in some ways, I think I played it better that way by recognizing, like this is a job, this is a guy, it's not me, But you have to, you've only got yourself to use, you know, for, yeah.
我没有，你知道，所以在某些方面，我认为我通过认识到，就像这是一份工作，这是一个人，这不是我，但你必须这样做，你只能用自己，你知道，为了，是的。
Do you think even unconsciously playing Ted for that long made you want to be less like Ted in your personal life?
你是否认为，即使无意识地扮演泰德那么长时间，你是否也不想在个人生活中变得不像泰德？
In some way, did it send you, did it make you not want to like settle down and find the girl and have that in your main drive?
在某种程度上，它是否给你带来了，它是否让你不想安定下来找到那个女孩并将其放在你的主要驱动器中？
Did it make you want to go have more adventures?
这是否让你想要去经历更多的冒险？
Well, I didn't get married until pretty late.
嗯，我很晚才结婚。
So maybe you know what I mean?
那么也许你明白我的意思？
Like that's far out of me and do you think that informed that at all?
这对我来说太遥远了，你认为这是否说明了这一点？
Like even on some very deep unconscious level where you're like, I'm, I did this for a decade, I'm not going to try to, I'm going to try to be something else in my life.
就像甚至在一些非常深的无意识层面上，你会说，我，我这样做了十年，我不会尝试这样做，我会尝试成为我生活中的其他人。
I just wonder if one informed the other.
我只是想知道一个人是否通知了另一个人。
I'd have to pay you a couple hundred dollars and have you be accredited a different way for me to start answering that.
我必须付给你几百美元，并让你以不同的方式获得认可，以便我开始回答这个问题。
All right, Craig.
好吧，克雷格。
Well, this is the part of the episode where we turn to our listener viewer mail.
好吧，这是本集的一部分，我们将转向听众观众的邮件。
We have a title for this segment yet.
我们还没有为这个片段定一个标题。
I was pitching how we read your letter.
我正在推销我们如何阅读你的信。
How we read your letters.
我们如何阅读您的来信。
I think pretty good.
我觉得还不错。
All right, let's go with it.
好吧，我们就这样吧。
it's thematically consistent.
它在主题上是一致的。
Let's do it.
我们开始做吧。
Branded.
品牌化。
Hashtag branded.
标签品牌。
Welcome to how we how we read your letter.
欢迎了解我们如何阅读您的来信。
If you want to write into us and tell us what how I met your mother means to you or any other beautiful beloved hilarious how I met your mother related story go to how we made your mother calm go to contact and it should be pretty clear from there right Alec?
如果你想写信给我们，告诉我们我如何遇见你母亲对你意味着什么，或者任何其他美丽可爱的搞笑我如何遇见你母亲相关的故事，请转到我们如何让你母亲平静去联系，从那里应该很清楚，对亚历克吗？
We love hearing from you guys Yeah, we do we really do this is very it's a meeting full to hear these letters.
我们很高兴收到你们的来信 是的，我们确实这样做，我们真的很高兴，这次会议充满了听到这些来信。
I'm going to read one This is from Serenity Hi Josh Hi Serenity how I met your mother has been my favorite show and has deeply impacted my life I've watched it literally countless times now growing up I have the complete series in DVD form the show deeply resonates with me It taught me the importance of patience Vulnerability and staying true to what I want in life life.
我要读一个 这是来自《宁静》的节目，嗨，乔什·嗨，《宁静，我如何遇见你母亲》是我最喜欢的节目，对我的生活产生了深远的影响。在成长过程中，我已经看过无数次了。我有完整的 DVD 版本，该节目与我产生了深刻的共鸣。它教会了我耐心、脆弱和忠于我在生活中想要的东西的重要性。
It may be believed that true love is worth waiting for and that every moment good or bad shapes who we become.
人们可能相信，真爱是值得等待的，每一刻的好坏都会塑造我们成为什么样的人。
I often find myself thinking about lessons from the show when navigating my own life.
我经常发现自己在自己的生活中思考着这部剧的教训。
It is influenced the way I approach love, friendship, and how I view the world in general.
它影响了我对待爱情、友谊的方式，以及我看待世界的方式。
It's a reminder to keep believing in love, to cherish the people around me, and to never give up on my dreams no matter how far away they might seem.
它提醒我要继续相信爱情，珍惜身边的人，永远不要放弃我的梦想，无论它们看起来有多遥远。
Thank you for bringing Ted to life in such an authentic way.
感谢您以如此真实的方式让泰德栩栩如生。
Your performance and the lessons the show expressed will always hold a special place in my heart and continue to shape who I am as a person wishing you the best serenity.
你的表演和节目所表达的教训将永远在我心中占有特殊的位置，并继续塑造我作为一个人，祝你拥有最好的平静。
Oh nice is that.
哦，太好了。
Thank you, serenity.
谢谢你，平静。
So beautiful.
如此美丽。
You know what occurred to me Craig when we're talking about you know part of this show is the mystery of what it is about this show why it's so beloved, why people keep watching it and watching it and showing it to their kids and quoting it.
你知道克雷格，当我们谈论你知道这个节目的一部分时，我想到了什么，这就是这个节目的神秘之处，为什么它如此受人喜爱，为什么人们不断地观看它并向他们的孩子展示它并引用它。
As I was reading that I thought But there's something about movies and TV, a lot of it presents an incredibly idealized version of life and a sanitized version of life.
当我读到这篇文章时，我想但是电影和电视有一些东西，其中很多都呈现了令人难以置信的理想化版本的生活和净化后的生活版本。
And I think something people find relieving about this show is it's actually, it's about as much about good time as bad times as good times.
我认为这部剧让人们感到宽慰的是，它实际上讲述了美好时光、坏时光和美好时光。
It's about people getting knocked down, holding those they love close and moving forward you know, wounded, but moving forward.
这是关于人们被击倒，紧紧拥抱他们所爱的人并继续前进，你知道，受伤，但继续前进。
It's a really a show, I think a big word is resilience.
这真的是一场表演，我认为一个重要的词就是韧性。
Certainly for Ted, when people say, why do you love Ted?
当然对于泰德来说，当人们问你为什么爱泰德时？
I said, he's the most resilient character.
我说，他是最有韧性的人物。
Yeah.
是的。
You know, he's like a bobblehead or like, you know, there's things get knocked down.
你知道，他就像一个摇头娃娃，或者像，你知道，有些东西会被撞倒。
They just pop back up.
他们只是突然回来。
Yeah, and I think that there's something people need to be reminded.
是的，我认为有些事情需要提醒人们。
Life is not a series.
生活不是一个系列。
You don't go from triumph to triumph to triumph.
你不会从一个胜利走向另一个胜利。
That's not a life you would want to live in.
那不是你想要的生活。
It's not a life where you're going to learn all that much.
这不是你能学到那么多东西的生活。
And when people talk about the most meaningful moments of their life, it's generally related to some heartbreak or setback or failure, where they were able to reassess, reprioritize, and how many other mothers just laced through with all of that.
当人们谈论生命中最有意义的时刻时，通常与一些心碎、挫折或失败有关，在这些时刻，他们能够重新评估、重新确定优先顺序，以及有多少其他母亲刚刚经历了这一切。
As I was listening to that letter, I was thinking, even with the shows I absolutely love, are there any other shows that someone would say this about.
当我听那封信时，我在想，即使有我非常喜欢的节目，还有其他节目有人会这么说吗？
They've influenced the way I approach love friendship and how I view the world in general.
他们影响了我对待爱情、友谊的方式以及我看待世界的方式。
Like that's not sign fell.
好像那不是坠落的迹象。
That was our that was our move.
这就是我们的行动。
We committed to our move very hard.
我们非常努力地致力于我们的行动。
We were not the funniest show.
我们不是最有趣的节目。
We were not the most joke dance show.
我们不是最搞笑的舞蹈表演。
I remember watching other shows like 30 rock and being like god damn they've got more jokes than we do and feeling insecure about it.
我记得看过其他节目，比如《30 rock》，天哪，他们的笑话比我们多，而且对此感到不安全。
But we said no it's okay.
但我们说不，没关系。
We're in our land.
我们在我们的土地上。
It's we're funny too but we're going to do this other thing.
我们也很有趣，但我们要做另一件事。
We're going to throw a bunch of the band with this other thing and in the end it seems to be what has resonated with people for the most, but it's interesting because I think part of the long tail of it because you encoded that into the DNA.
我们将在乐队中加入一些其他东西，最终它似乎是最能引起人们共鸣的东西，但这很有趣，因为我认为它是长尾的一部分，因为你将其编码到 DNA 中。
Yeah, it made it into a classic and it made it into a show that people still are watching and talk about because if you're doing, if you're going to do, this is not a slam against any show, but if you're going to do purely a joke show, you actually are in danger of it aging pretty quickly because it tastes in comedy change.
是的，它使它成为一部经典，它使它成为一个人们仍在观看和谈论的节目，因为如果你正在这样做，如果你打算这样做，这并不是对任何节目的猛烈攻击，但如果你打算纯粹做一个笑话节目，你实际上面临着它很快老化的危险，因为它尝起来有喜剧变化的味道。
Yes.
是的。
And references change.
并且参考文献发生了变化。
Yeah.
是的。
But if you do a show that's really about these perennial ideas about love, friendship, family, resilience, good times, bad times, weathering good times, bad times, like you have a better shot at creating something a little more timeless.
但如果你制作的节目真正是关于爱情、友谊、家庭、韧性、好时光、坏时光、经受好时光、坏时光等永恒观念的节目，那么你就有更好的机会创造一些更永恒的东西。
Yeah.
是的。
It's kind of are you a cartoon or are you a movie?
有点像你是卡通片还是电影？
Even if you're a sitcom, you can steer it either way and we're definitely more a movie.
即使你是一部情景喜剧，你也可以选择任何一种方式，而我们绝对更像是一部电影。
And occasionally a cartoon by a Barney.
偶尔还有巴尼的漫画。
Okay, speaking of amazing letters from our fans, this letter comes from Vic.
好吧，说到我们粉丝的精彩来信，这封信来自维克。
I really appreciate it if you share this.
如果您分享这个，我真的很感激。
I'm gonna try to not get emotional while I read this one.
当我读这篇文章时，我会尽量不情绪激动。
Okay, here we go.
好的，我们开始吧。
Himium has a special place in my heart that it's hard to put into words.
Himium 在我心中有着难以言喻的特殊地位。
It was the one thing that brought me comfort in the most difficult time of my life.
这是在我一生中最困难的时刻给我带来安慰的一件事。
My son was born needing an organ transplant, 2011, which meant we lived in the hospital for months at a time.
2011 年，我的儿子出生，需要进行器官移植，这意味着我们一次在医院住了几个月。
I was already a fan, watched on television, but it was the seasons on DVD that ultimately allowed me to if only even for an episode, unload all of the worry and stress and just laugh and get lost in all the amazingly written directed acted adventures with the gang.
我已经是一名粉丝，在电视上观看过，但正是 DVD 上的季节最终让我能够卸下所有的担忧和压力，哪怕只是一集，只是开怀大笑，迷失在与这帮人一起编写的所有令人惊叹的导演表演冒险中。
Season one is classic starting to set up the gags and groundwork for our group.
第一季是经典的开始，为我们的团队设置了笑料和基础。
I apologize for the length of this.
对于本文的长度，我深表歉意。
I appreciate whoever reads this.
我很感激读到这篇文章的人。
Thank you, Craig Thomas and Carter Bayes and thank you, Josh Radner for bringing Ted to life for so many years.
谢谢克雷格·托马斯和卡特·贝叶斯，谢谢乔什·拉德纳这么多年给泰德带来了生命。
Thank you all for creating and producing this podcast.
感谢大家创建和制作这个播客。
I wanna talk about why that means so much to me and I'll definitely talk about this more later in the podcast when we get up to the part in the series where I went through something very similar to this.
我想谈谈为什么这对我来说意义重大，当我们进入系列中我经历过与此非常相似的事情的部分时，我肯定会在播客中更多地谈论这一点。
Between your two and three of how I met your mother and my son was born and we had no idea until he was born that he had something called Jacob's syndrome which meant it's a genetic deletion where he's missing a part of one of his 11th chromosomes.
在你两到三岁的时间里，我认识了你的母亲，我的儿子出生了，直到他出生我们才知道他患有一种叫做雅各布氏综合症的疾病，这意味着这是一种基因缺失，他的第 11 条染色体中的一条染色体缺失了一部分。
It meant that he needed open heart surgery at two weeks old, weighing about three and a half pounds, it meant that he would have a lifelong health problems and developmental challenges.
这意味着他在两周大时需要进行心脏直视手术，体重约为三磅半，这意味着他将面临终生的健康问题和发育挑战。
It meant that he would be, you know, he would be on a different journey.
这意味着他将踏上不同的旅程。
He would be, we would be now special needs parents.
他将是，我们现在将成为有特殊需要的父母。
And we would be, we would be living sort of a different life than we thought we would be.
我们将会过着与我们想象的不同的生活。
And then it was, you know, year three being ended.
然后，你知道，第三年结束了。
It was like, let's get back into the writers and we always, I always used to joke to Carter.
就像，让我们回到编剧身上，我们总是，我总是对卡特开玩笑。
And now go be funny.
现在就变得有趣吧。
You just, we spent six weeks in the NICU, the neonatal intensive of Care Unit at Children's Hospital of LA, which saved my son's life.
你只是，我们在洛杉矶儿童医院的新生儿重症监护室 NICU 度过了六个星期，这挽救了我儿子的生命。
Thank you, C-H-L-A.
谢谢你，C-H-L-A。
And, you know, my son is 17 now and doing great.
而且，你知道，我儿子现在 17 岁了，表现得很好。
And the making of the show, when we went back and started doing season three, getting the escape of making this show with these wonderful people who I loved and all the writers and Pam Freiman and Suzy and Josh Radner and the whole cast, getting to escape into this other universe that was a universe full of love, a show about love and a show about the hard times, making those episodes got me through the darkest time in my life.
当我们回去开始制作第三季时，我们逃离了与我所爱的这些出色的人以及所有编剧、帕姆·弗雷曼、苏西和乔什·拉德纳以及整个演员一起制作这部剧的过程，逃离到另一个充满爱的宇宙，一个关于爱的节目和一个关于艰难时期的节目，制作这些剧集让我度过了人生中最黑暗的时期。
So then when I hear from fans, as we just see with that letter, that the show helped them get through their hard time.
因此，当我从粉丝那里听到时，正如我们刚刚从那封信中看到的那样，这部剧帮助他们度过了困难时期。
Well, it did that for me.
嗯，它为我做到了。
And I think some of that energy made it into the show, as everybody on the show rallied around me.
我认为这种能量的一部分融入到了节目中，因为节目中的每个人都聚集在我周围。
Josh, you rallied around me.
乔什，你聚集在我身边。
You would always, we would sit there and have long talks after the rap at the bar, and we would sit there and we would talk about what it was going through in Pam Fryman would be there in Susie and Carter and all the writers.
你总是会，我们会坐在那里，在酒吧的说唱结束后进行长时间的交谈，我们会坐在那里，我们会谈论帕姆·弗莱曼（Pam Fryman）、苏西（Susie）和卡特（Carter）以及所有作家所经历的事情。
And it just meant the world to me.
它对我来说意味着整个世界。
And I think the show sort of took on some of that energy for me and with me.
我认为这部剧为我和我带来了一些能量。
And when I hear that it connects to people to this day who've gone through things like that, like, I know what it's like to be in that NICU, in that hospital for weeks and weeks on end not knowing if your kid's going to live or die.
当我听到它时，它与那些经历过类似事情的人们联系在一起，就像，我知道在新生儿重症监护病房里，在那家医院里连续几周不知道你的孩子是生还是死是什么感觉。
And my son could have not made it.
我儿子不可能成功。
But he made it.
但他做到了。
17 now and yeah, I just, that was my journey throughout the middle part of how much your mother and now I just have this wonderful human being who's 17, who I play music with, he plays the drums, I play the guitar, he's got all these amazing strengths and things I never could have imagined when he was first born and so many gifts.
17岁了，是的，我只是，这就是我的旅程，你的母亲，现在我有一个很棒的人，他17岁，我和他一起演奏音乐，他打鼓，我弹吉他，他拥有所有这些惊人的优势和我在他刚出生时从未想象过的东西，还有这么多的天赋。
And I will just say now, thank you for sharing that story, it means the world to me, it's what I went through, the fact that it helped the show helped you get through what you we were going through.
我现在只想说，谢谢你分享这个故事，这对我来说意味着整个世界，这就是我所经历的，事实上它帮助了这个节目帮助你度过了我们正在经历的事情。
And even in some small way, it means the world.
即使在某种程度上，它也意味着整个世界。
That's why that's what the show, that's when we made the show, that's what the show was to me and making the show.
这就是为什么这就是这个节目，这就是我们制作这个节目的原因，这就是这个节目对我和制作这个节目的意义。
So thank you so much.
非常感谢。
And I would just say that we will talk more about this.
我只想说我们会更多地讨论这个问题。
We will talk about more, more about how sort of this big life chapter change for me.
我们将更多地谈论这一重大的人生篇章对我来说有何改变。
And what I went through, sort of informed how much your mother and in those seasons and stuff, we're not there yet.
我所经历的事情，告诉你的母亲，在那些季节之类的事情上，我们还没有达到那个程度。
We just finished talking about episode three.
我们刚刚讲完第三集。
So I won't believe it for too long, but I will say Josh and Alec and my wonderful friends making this podcast with me have all embraced sort of the fundraising and the cause that helps kids like my son.
所以我不会相信太久，但我会说乔什和亚历克以及我和我一起制作这个播客的好朋友都接受了筹款和帮助像我儿子这样的孩子的事业。
It is part of the podcast thanks to them.
感谢他们，它成为播客的一部分。
And if you go to our website howwemadeyourmother.com and you go to the section called How You Make a Difference.
如果您访问我们的网站 howwemadeyourmother.com，您会看到名为“如何发挥作用”的部分。
You can read all about the work being done by this amazing doctor named Dr. Paul Grossfeld out of UCSD, Reddy's Children's Hospital in San Diego.
您可以阅读有关来自圣地亚哥加州大学圣地亚哥分校雷迪儿童医院的 Paul Grossfeld 博士的出色医生所做工作的所有信息。
And he is the worldwide expert in Jacobson syndrome.
他是雅各布森综合症的全球专家。
He is working to do research to help kids born with contendable heart defects of all different kinds including the kind my son had Including Jacob Simpson's syndrome and the specifics about that and the developmental stuff He is like the the X the worldwide expert in my son's condition among many other He's a great dude.
他正在努力进行研究，以帮助出生时患有各种不同类型心脏缺陷的孩子，包括我儿子患有的那种，包括雅各布·辛普森综合症，以及有关此病的具体情况和发育方面的内容。他就像是 X，是我儿子病情方面的全球专家，他是一个很棒的人。
He's and he's like the best student in the world that Josh and I and I we've all become dear friends with him now He the impact he's made on my life and the community of parents like me is it can't it can't be overstated He's like a guiding light as this candle in the darkness And so we raised money for him via this podcast.
他是世界上最好的学生，乔什和我，我们现在都成为了他的好朋友，他对我的生活和像我这样的父母社区产生的影响是不能被夸大的，他就像黑暗中的一盏指路明灯，就像这支蜡烛，所以我们通过这个播客为他筹集了资金。
So please go to howemadeyourmother.com, click on make a difference, and you can read about that work.
因此，请访问 howemadeyourmother.com，点击“make a Difference”，然后您就可以阅读有关该作品的信息。
If you feel like supporting this amazing work, this like ground-breaking, life-saving work that Paul Grossfeld does in San Diego, please, if you can contribute and support or get the word out about it, we'd be honored.
如果您愿意支持这项令人惊叹的工作，就像保罗·格罗斯菲尔德在圣地亚哥所做的开创性的、拯救生命的工作，如果您能贡献和支持或宣传它，我们将感到荣幸。
And thank you so much to everybody out there and the Himian fandom that for sharing your vulnerability and sharing your life stories with me to this effect, it means the world to me to hear it.
非常感谢那里的所有人和希米安粉丝们，感谢你们与我分享你们的脆弱，并与我分享你们的生活故事，这对我来说意味着世界。
So thank you.
所以谢谢你。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins are forgiven.
所有的罪孽都被宽恕了。
New York City.
纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted an executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯担任执行制片人主持。
The show was produced by me, Alec Webb.
该剧由我亚历克·韦伯制作。
And our co-producer is Doug Matica.
我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point de Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point de Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Art work by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connerts.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《NYC》，特别感谢 Lola Kennedy 和 Elliot Connerts。
Visit howwemadeyourmother.com to sign up for our substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemadeyourmother.com 注册我们的子堆栈邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Riders' newsletters on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Riders 的时事通讯。
Read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com and you can subscribe to my dead father's society also on Substack.
阅读 Craig Thomas 在 CraigThomasRider.com 上发表的散文，您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我已故父亲的社团。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持和 Tink Media 的营销支持下得以实现的。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。
The real question, it just hit me.
真正的问题，它刚刚击中了我。
Am I in love with you or just new York City?
我爱的是你还是只爱纽约市？